bien bonsoir à toutes et à tous chers
collègues nous recevons ce soir dans le
cadre des auditions de notre commission
d'enquête visant établir les raisons de
la perte de souveraineté d'indépendance
énergétique de la France une
personnalité qui connaît bien cette
maison Monsieur François de Rugy puisque
vous allez présider l'Assemblée
nationale au début de la précédente
législature avant de devenir ministre
d'État ministre de la transition
écologique et solidaire je vais revenir
là-dessus mais en préambule j'aimerais
simplement préciser aux membres de notre
commission d'enquête et
à ceux qui suivent nos travaux qu'il
s'agit là de la dernière audition qui
sera la nôtre avant
d'entamer une phase de travail de
rédaction du rapport et de recevoir les
deux anciens présidents de la République
la semaine prochaine dans un cadre un
peu différent puisque en tant
qu'enseigne président de la République
ils ne sont pas responsables devant le
Parlement en leur qualité d'anciens
présidents de la République et donc le
format de nos auditions sera un peu
différent l'occasion pour moi du coup de
souligner que
nous entaquent nous attaquons la 142e
heure d'audition de notre commission
d'enquête ce soir ce qui est une
quantité d'audition et de travail
relativement conséquente pour une
commission d'enquête parlementaire et
j'aimerais donc en profiter pour
remercier d'abord
les administrateurs et le secrétariat de
cette commission je tiens à le faire
publiquement pour la disponibilité la
qualité du travail déjà fournie c'est
vrai que c'est très agréable en tant que
élu de la Nation de pouvoir nous reposer
sur une administration aussi disponible
et au service du travail des
parlementaires remercier également
l'ensemble des collègues qui ont
participé aux travaux de cette
commission pour la qualité des questions
pour l'ambiance aussi et pour le respect
qui a
émané animé l'ensemble de nos auditions
successives ce n'est pas forcément
évident pour un sujet qui était un sujet
clivant sur le plan politique mais je
pense que nous y sommes parvenus voilà
monsieur le Président merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté de venir devant notre
commission pour partager avec nous vos
analyses vous allez donc été président
de l'Assemblée nationale en 2017 avant
d'être nommé ministre d'État après la
démission de Monsieur Nicolas Hulot que
nous avons auditionné avant vous
votre Athènes analyse en tant qu' ancien
président de l'Assemblée nationale
ancien député nous intéresse évidemment
les auditions organisées par notre
commission d'enquête on est fait montrer
l'importance que pouvait avoir les
dispositions votées par le Parlement
dans le domaine de l'énergie
vous avez été élus député en 2007 puis
réélu en 2012 et 2017 vous avez par
ailleurs présidé le groupe écologiste de
l'assemblée de 2012 à 2016
comme vous le savez la Loire relative à
la transition énergétique pour la
croissance verte du 17 août 2015 a fait
l'objet dans le cadre de notre
commission de nombreux commentaires
notamment sur la qualité de l'étude
d'impact et des outils de programmation
destinés à donner à la représentation
nationale les moyens d'information et de
suivi nécessaire vous avez ensuite été
ministre d'État ministre de la
transition écologique et solidaire de
2018 à 2019 période marquée par le
mouvement des gilets jaunes et le
lancement de deux événements importants
le grand débat national et la convention
citoyenne pour le climat vous avez été
signataire avec le Premier ministre
d'alors Edouard Philippe du projet de
loi relatif à l'énergie et au climat
adopter après votre départ du ministère
son exposé des motifs fait état de la
substitution de la neutralité carbone au
facteur 4
qui a largement été discuté aussi dans
nos travaux comme étant un point de
rupture et annonce le délai que le délai
au terme duquel le mix électrique devra
comprendre au plus 50% de nucléaire
repoussé à 2035 en précisant que cela je
cite correspond à la fermeture de 14
réacteurs sur la période dont deux à
quatre d'ici 2028 en plus de ce de
Fessenheim vous êtes par ailleurs un
homme politique appartenant au mouvement
écologiste qui a été traversé par
différents courants et exprimés parfois
votre désaccord avec certaines
orientations vos réflexions sur les
conditions dans lesquelles la politique
énergétique notre pays est définie les
leçons que vous tirez de votre
expérience politique enrichiront celles
que nous avons d'ores et déjà recueilli
auprès d'autres personnalités que nous
avons auditionnées il me revient donc
avant de vous laisser la parole monsieur
le Président en application de
l'ordonnance du 17 novembre 1958
relative au fonctionnement des
assemblées parlementaires de vous
demander de bien vouloir prêter serment
de dire la vérité toute la vérité et
rien que la vérité je vous prie donc de
bien vouloir lever la main droite et
dire je le jure je le jure monsieur le
Président je vous laisse donc la parole
pour un propos introductif merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
rapporteur
mesdames messieurs d'abord je voudrais
saluer la création de cette commission
d'enquête c'est assez rare sur ce sujet
alors il y en a déjà eu en 2014 mais qui
portait sur les coups de la filière
nucléaire donc je crois qu'il y a des
sujets qui se recoupent et je ne doute
pas que elle vous permettra à vous les
députés et qu'en tout cas c'est votre
objectif d'aller au plus près de la
vérité de ce qu'est la réalité non
seulement de la situation énergétique
actuelle mais de ce qui a amené à cette
situation alors vous m'avez envoyé pour
préparer cette audition un certain
nombre de questions je vais essayer d'y
répondre dans ce petit propos
introductif évidemment je compléterai
aussi
de par les questions que vous aurez
peut-être après je parlais d'approcher
la vérité manifestement évidemment ce
n'est pas facile si j'en crois quelques
trous de mémoire de certaines
personnalités que vous avez auditionnées
ou aussi parfois de l'incapacité à
d'autres à assumer ce qui était leur
responsabilité donc pour ma part
j'essaierai de répondre aussi
précisément que possible à vos questions
et également d'assumer les
responsabilités qui ont été les miennes
au gouvernement donc je m'exprimerai
surtout en tant qu' ancien ministre de
l'écologie donc de l'énergie
entre 2018 et 2019 et je n'oublie pas
vous l'avez fait mention que j'ai été
député de nombreuses années que j'ai
suivi à ce titre les débats
parlementaires législatif sur un certain
nombre de textes qui ont pris des
décisions en matière énergétique je
crois pouvoir dire que le débat
politique actuel sur l'énergie est
beaucoup plus intense qui n'a plus
l'être par le passé
cela amène peut-être parfois à des
choses un petit peu caricaturales mais
je m'en félicite parce que je crois que
c'est dommage que pendant de très
nombreuses décennies en France
finalement il n'y ait pas eu beaucoup de
débats alors il faut reconnaître ça n'a
pas commencé aujourd'hui
il y a eu en 2005 une loi sur l'énergie
qui déjà à l'époque parallèles des
objectifs climatiques parler d'ailleurs
d'un mix comme on dit souvent
énergétique électrique en tout cas qui
soit à la fois composé du nucléaire et
des énergies renouvelables il y a eu en
2010 la loi nomme qui a pris des
décisions importantes sur
le marché électrique et notamment la
question de la Reine qui a dû souvent
être débattue ici et évidemment en 2015
plus près de nous vous en avez parlé la
loi de transition énergétique et de
croissance verte encore un peu plus près
de nous c'est moins connu et c'est moins
peut-être directement perçu comme à
votre sujet pourtant ça l'est une loi en
2017 à la fin de l'année 2017 présentait
à l'époque par le ministre Nicolas Hulot
interdisant tout exploration et
production d'hydrocarbures en France
alors on pourrait penser que ça n'a pas
de conséquence parce qu'après tout nous
ne sommes pas un pays qui recèle
beaucoup de ressources en la matière
d'abord
il y en a quand même par exemple sans
aucun doute au large de la Guyane
aujourd'hui on s'interdit de rechercher
d'ailleurs total avait eu un permis
avant cette loi et l'a utilisé il n'a
pas trouvé de pétrole tout le monde
savait qu'il y avait de fortes chances
qu'il y en ait sur des zones proches bon
il n'a pas pu demander un nouveau permis
et surtout les gaz et pétrole de schiste
qui là sont assez abondants sous nos
pieds si on peut dire sous le sous-sol
français dans beaucoup de régions
françaises c'est un choix assez
consensuel je crois on peut le dire qui
est de s'interdire des exploiter en
termes de souveraineté énergétique ça
n'est pas neutre notamment aujourd'hui
où on voit à quel point évidemment
l'alimentation notamment en gaz est un
sujet difficile en 2019 vous l'avez
mentionné j'ai moi-même présenté en
Conseil des ministres et ensuite en
première lecture à l'Assemblée nationale
un projet de loi énergique climat qui a
eu qui a amené à prendre des décisions
sur ces sujets en complément de ce que
nous avions présenté lors de la
programmation plus réelle de l'énergie
alors la situation de la production
d'électricité parce que je crois que on
parle beaucoup en réalité de
l'électricité plus que de l'énergie j'y
reviendrai à un moment rapidement quand
même en donnant quelques chiffres mais
en réalité quand moi je suis arrivé
ministre en 2018 la situation était
relativement stable depuis de très
nombreuses années et si on regarde les
chiffres vous l'avez fait évidemment
sur les 30 dernières années
on avait une très grande stabilité en
France de la production
électro-nucléaire de la production
hydraulique ça c'était vraiment les deux
piliers très stables les deux seuls
changements qui commençaient à se sentir
depuis on va dire 5 années
principalement peut-être 10 c'était le
déclin des centrales thermiques
on en parle très peu mais ce n'est pas
une décision politique pour une part
c'est une décision de l'entreprise EDF
qui a fait le choix de fermer des
centrales au fioul un exemple deux
tranches fuel à Cordemais il y a
toujours deux tranches charmants mais il
y avait deux tranches qui ont été formés
Porcheville dans les Yvelines
intégralement fermées
par un choix d'entreprise et puis aussi
le développement des énergies
renouvelables qui est quand même
sensible sur cette période l'éolien est
le solaire principalement encore une
fois on parle de l'électricité si on
parle du reste de l'énergie il y a
d'autres sujets la situation en 2017
2018 j'ai 2017-2018 je suis arrivé au
gouvernement en septembre 2018 donc on
regarde toujours ce qui s'est passé on a
des chiffres de l'année précédente etc
ce caractériser par quelque chose que
aujourd'hui on a beaucoup de mal à
imaginer mais c'est vérifiable
naturellement des prix extrêmement bas
de l'électricité sur les marchés de gros
en Europe
on peut regarder évidemment c'est des
moyennes mais marcher de gros je dis
bien c'est pas le marché spot à quelques
un instant T mais en moyenne les
contrats de gros inférieur à 40 euros le
mégawattheure évidemment aujourd'hui ça
paraît complètement surréaliste d'avoir
des prix aussi bas les concurrents de DF
en France ne faisaient même pas appel à
la reine à laquelle ils avaient accès
parce que c'était à 42 euros à l'époque
trop cher par rapport au prix de marché
ensuite on a dû monter vers 50 euros en
2018 d'ailleurs on l'oublie mais à la
fin sur l'année 2021 on était encore à
des prix de cet ordre là
l'Europe en réalité à ce moment-là
puisque nous sommes inscrits dans un
marché européen
est plutôt en situation de surproduction
pourquoi parce que il y a eu un
développement assez fort des
renouvelables dans beaucoup de pays qui
ont mis de l'électricité sur le marché
on peut considérer entre guillemets à
kuzzero puisque de toute façon elle
était achetée à un prix c'est d'avance
ça c'est évidemment développé plus dans
certains pays mais ça a pesé sur un
marché et dans le même temps en tout cas
à cette époque là les capacités
classiques étaient maintenues parce que
les gouvernements avaient un petit peu
plus de mal toujours plus difficile de
fermer des centrales que dans l'ouvrir
donc dans un premier temps il y avait eu
ce mouvement d'augmentation de la
production sans avoir sur le
renouvelable sans baisser le classique
ça avait une conséquence quand même très
concrète et je crois que d'autres
personnes que vous avez auditionné le
relevé cela n'incite pas les
énergéticiens petits ou grand d'ailleurs
à investir puisque évidemment il n'y a
pas tellement de rentabilité économique
je rappelle qu'à l'époque je crois que
le chiffre n'a pas beaucoup changé
d'ailleurs l'éolien l'électricité
produite par les éoliennes considérer
que c'était environ 70 euros le
mégawattheure le coup
donc évidemment quand vous êtes sur un
marché qui tourne entre 40 et 50 70
euros ça paraît très cher je rappelle
aussi que il y a eu ça a été un peu
oublié mais en 2010 vous avez auditionné
madame cosciusko-morizet donc elle vous
en a peut-être parlé on a brutalement
stoppé le développement du solaire
photovoltaïque en France a eu un décret
qui a cassé 13000 emplois ont été
supprimés on a tous stoppé pendant six
mois au motif que ça marchait trop bien
c'est à dire que la production
commençait entre guillemets à s'emballer
au lieu de réguler le système et en
baissant un petit peu le coup et le prix
de d'achat mais ce qui aurait permis de
continuer à développer davantage cette
filière et puis surtout le nucléaire à
l'époque inclipoint le projet porté par
EDF pour le Royaume-Uni on considère
avec les taux de change avec le contrat
est signé aux alentours de 90 à 100
euros le mégawattheure 90 à 100
d'ailleurs certains au Royaume-Uni avait
reproché au gouvernement britannique de
signer un contrat à ce prix même si
évidemment c'était à échéance de ans
après le contrat parce que il trouvait
que c'était beaucoup trop cher par
rapport au marché que j'avais des
échanges moi-même avec mes homologues
britanniques quand j'étais ministre et
me disait bon pour l'instant on va pas
plus loin sur le nucléaire parce que
c'est plus cher que d'autres modes de
production quand j'ai été nommé ministre
la programmation plus réelle de
l'énergie qui était le décret
d'application
le décret d'application de la loi de
transition énergétique de 2015 n'était
toujours pas finalisé alors il y avait
eu un choix qui avait été fait par le
gouvernement précédent je trouve que
j'ai soutenu en tant que député le
gouvernement précédent donc je peux en
parler très tranquillement mais que ce
choix là je ne le partageais pas qui
était de dire on renvoie à 2017 la
définition d'une vraie PPE donc en 2015
après l'adoption de la loi il y a eu un
décret qui a été fait mais qui ne se
contentait de dire on provoque
l'existant et en quelque sorte on disait
d'une façon un peu triviale on refile le
bébé au gouvernement suivant quand moi
j'arrive à l'automne 2018
beaucoup de travail a été fait mais rien
n'est finalisé plusieurs scénarios
pour appliquer cette loi très vite
qu'est-ce que nous faisons nous prenons
des décisions dans un cadre qui est un
cadre politique qui est les engagements
du Président de la République Emmanuel
Macron qui avant d'être élu a fait
campagne et a dit dans sa campagne voilà
moi je m'inscris dans le cadre de la loi
2015 c'est ce qu'il avait dit et c'était
je la mettrais en œuvre contrairement à
d'autres candidats qui avaient d'autres
points de vue et c'était le cadre
politique je le dis parce que souvent on
dit les candidats une fois élus ne
respectent pas leurs promesses je pense
que d'ailleurs vous interrogerez les
anciens présidents de la République et
ils pourront démontrer sans grande
difficulté qu'ils ont plutôt tenu leur
promesse que ce soit François Hollande
Nicolas Sarkozy avant lui ou Emmanuel
Macron en tant que président élu en 2017
une feuille de route était donc ma
feuille de route en tant que ministre
fixée par le Président le gouvernement
le était de mettre en oeuvre cet
engagement et de finaliser la
programmation
avec l'insistance qu'il avait eu sur le
développement des énergies renouvelables
et le maintien d'une part important de
nucléaire je tiens quand même à le dire
parce que quand j'entends certaines
auditions on a l'impression que Emmanuel
Macron était anti-nucléaire il a jamais
été anti-nucléaire il n'a jamais fait la
moindre déclaration ensemble je rappelle
que quand il était ministre de
l'économie c'est lui qui a beaucoup
poussé à la signature du contrat
inklepoint avec le Royaume-Uni pour EDF
nous décidons c'est le premier point de
reporter l'échéance de 2025 à 2035 ça
c'est ce qui a été vous l'avez rappelé
monsieur le Président
acté dans la loi parce qu'il fallait le
mettre dans la loi en 2019
vous je pourrais revenir bien sûr sur ce
contexte de l'époque je peux simplement
dire que
il était évidemment le débat politique
n'était pas du tout structuré comme il
l'est maintenant et notamment le débat
médiatique et j'y reviendrai si vous
avez des questions la situation actuelle
vous m'avez demandé mon point de vue mon
analyse sur la situation actuelle
c'est pas la peine de tourner autour du
pot elle est très dégradée
et cela tient pour moi la conjonction de
deux phénomènes qui étaient totalement
imprévisible en
2017-2018 ou même 2019 quand j'ai quitté
mes fonctions premier phénomène il faut
pas l'oublier ça le point phénomène la
baisse des moyens de production
classique partout en Europe et notamment
thermique puisque beaucoup de pays
d'Europe décident de fermer leur
centrale thermique pour remplir des
objectifs climatiques je rappelle que
pour beaucoup de pays d'Europe
contrairement à la France la production
d'électricité pèse lourd dans leurs
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
donc fermez les centrales thermiques ça
permet assez rapidement de baisser les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
l'Allemagne ferme également des
centrales nucléaires nous sommes dans un
marché européen
il y a une politique européenne très
forte et je crois que France François
brode que vous avez auditionné a
insister sur ce point à juste titre les
interconnexions l'Union européenne
subventionne un site beaucoup à ce
qu'ils interconnexion très bonne chose
d'ailleurs mais il y a un problème que
j'ai pu constater quand j'étais ministre
c'est qu'il n'y a pas de coordination
entre les gouvernements européens sur la
production on a le même marché on a le
même réseau interconnecté mais chaque
pays est très jaloux ou même l'intitulé
de votre commission c'est la
souveraineté et très jaloux de ses choix
en matière énergétique et donc il est
très compliqué de coordonner la
production
et puis l'autre phénomène la conjonction
je disais de deux phénomènes c'est la
chute jamais vu de disponibilité du parc
nucléaire français je dis bien de
disponibilité c'est la capacité des
centrales nucléaires à produire de
l'électricité à l'inverse je tiens à le
dire de tout ce que nous avait dit les
responsables de def en tout cas pendant
toute la période où j'étais c'est
incontestable je signale au passage que
le problème c'est poser de la même façon
avec un petit décalage dans le temps
chez nos voisins belges en Belgique
et d'ailleurs c'est engie entreprise
française qui opère en Belgique les
centrales nucléaires parce que elle
avait racheté Electrabel qui est
l'ancien opérateur historique le EDF
belge si on peut dire et
en Belgique aujourd'hui il y a une
décision du gouvernement belge
d'ailleurs sont remises en cause de
fermer mais à l'époque c'était pas une
décision politique c'était l'incapacité
à produire en toute sécurité et donc la
fermeture totalement imprévisible à
l'époque en Belgique phénomène donc qui
se produit en France en 2022 et il faut
le rappeler aussi
l'incapacité d'EDF encore à ce jour à
mettre le père de Flamanville en service
je peux dire alors là avec une certaine
antériorité à la fois comme député puis
communiste puis de nouveau comme députés
puis aujourd'hui comme observateur que
on nous a dit que quasiment chaque année
ce serait l'année prochaine
que tout était allait être réglé que les
problèmes à être reliés etc ce n'est pas
le cas malheureusement je dis
malheureusement parce que c'est
évidemment des moyens de production dont
nous avons besoin s'ajoute à cela c'est
moins important mais ça joue un rôle des
retards sur le parc et les parcs éoliens
en mer et je dois le dire parce que
c'est votre travail de parlementaire de
législateur le Conseil d'État a pris une
décision qui est assez lourde de
conséquences puisqu'il a donné droit à
des associations d'habitants du littoral
d'être considéré comme les associations
de riverains ayant intérêt à agir pour
contester des projets éoliens finalement
ils ont eu tort sur le fond mais sur la
forme après des décisions à deux niveaux
de juridiction qui les déboutait on a
considéré qu'ils avaient droit je
rappelle que les parcs éoliens en mer en
France notamment le premier en
Loire-Atlantique c'est à 12 km du
littoral que le débat politique ici au
Parlement quand Nicolas Sarkozy était
président de la République puis François
Hollande puis Emmanuel Macron était de
dire on développe l'éolien en mer
justement parce qu'il n'y aura pas de
problème avec les contrairement à
l'éolien terrestre c'est un problème et
aussi le retard sur quelques moyens de
production comme la centrale à gaz de
Landivisiau également pour des questions
de recours vous m'avez demandé ce qu'il
en était dans notre processus de
décision de la question de la
souveraineté puisque c'est votre sujet
et c'est tout à fait légitime d'abord
moi je voudrais rappeler que la
consommation d'énergie en France ne se
limite pas à l'électricité il y a une
petite ambiguïté parce que dans
l'intitulé de votre commission on parle
bien de la souveraineté énergétique mais
je vois bien que dans tous les débats on
vient vers l'électricité
c'est quand même important de le redire
aux Français on peut dire globalement
c'est c'est les chiffres d'une année à
l'autre mais la consommation d'énergie
en France tout confondu c'est 1600
terawattheure
l'électricité
normalement en tout cas quand le parc
nucléaire était avec un bon niveau de
disponibilité 400 euros 400 MW pardon
terawater 450 donc un peu plus de 25% du
total mais ça veut dire que le reste
c'est son encore pour une grande part
des énergies fossiles je rappelle donc
pétrole 680 terawatts gaz 320 tt charbon
l'oublie un peu il y a encore un peu 12
terawatters 100% importé 100% importé je
le rappelle quand même parce que là
c'est un problème de souveraineté qui
est majeur
il n'y a déficit commercial je crois que
ça a été redit en 2022 la contribution
de l'énergie au déficites commerciales
et de 44 milliards d'euros 44 milliards
d'euros
donc voilà
cela a toujours été au coeur de nos
décisions mais il faut le dire aussi
dans un cadre et dans une réflexion à la
fois technologique et économique alors
il y a eu le quoi qu'il en coûte il est
encore aujourd'hui d'actualité mais
c'est sûr que on n'était pas dans une
logique de on fait les projets quoi
qu'il en coûte parce que quand même
dimension économique majeure
moi je n'ai jamais manqué de rappeler
quand j'étais ministre dans mes
interventions publiques que ce soit ici
au Parlement que ce soit dans les médias
la nécessité de la sécurité
d'approvisionnement en électricité
et combien de fois cela systématiquement
était balayé d'un revers de la main par
les médias qui considéraient que si je
disais ça c'était pour faire diversion
pourquoi parce qu'à l'époque c'était une
évidence
on allume l'électricité enfin on branche
le compteur on branche un appareil
électrique il y a toujours d'électricité
c'était devenu un geste d'une banalité
totale et avec vraiment on peut le dire
une énergie une électricité relativement
abondante et relativement bon marché le
président de la République a parlé de la
fin de l'abondance il avait tout à fait
raison notamment sur ce point mais cette
prise de conscience n'existait pas du
tout à l'époque le contexte médiatique
je tiens à le dire et c'est vérifiable
était les deux questions qu'on me posait
tout le temps c'est quand est-ce que
vous allez fermer les centrales
nucléaires quand est-ce que vous allez
fermer les centrales à charbon voilà
c'était les deux choses je parlais de la
sécurité d'approvisionnement rien à
faire c'était quelque chose qui était vu
comme une diversion ce qui est très
grave donc dans ce contexte là la
souveraineté maintenir le nucléaire je
l'ai dit c'était l'engagement du
président de la République développer
les renouvelables car je le rappelle les
renouvelables et la au delà de la simple
électricité ce sont les ressources de
nos territoires c'est du France l'éolien
c'est le vent qui souffle en France le
solaire c'est le soleil qui brille
évidemment en France mais ne l'oublions
pas c'est pas l'électricité c'est le
biogaz c'est bien sûr l'hydroélectricité
mais là il y a une difficulté à
développer la production hydraulique car
les potentiels sont déjà très fortement
exploitées et plus personne n'envisage
de barrer des vallées alpine ou
pyrénéennes pour mettre des gros
barrages et surtout le la filière
également pour les forêts la chaleur
renouvelable l'éolien en mer c'est
concret c'est moi qui ai débloqué c'est
quand j'étais ministre que c'est
débloqué le projet de Saint-Nazaire il
est d'ailleurs à en service on avait dit
qu'il serait en service à l'automne 2022
il a été en service et le produit de
l'électricité depuis l'automne dernier
mais c'est surtout moi qui est lancé et
qui est plus attribué le parc éolien de
Dunkerque qui au passage je le rappelle
alors lui est un coût qui est
extrêmement bas il y a une très forte
concurrence 10 groupements dont
évidemment les plus grands EDF engie
total etc
concourue c'est ed qui l'emportait parce
que c'est le prix c'est lui qui avait
proposé le prix le plus bas et qui est
de mémoire de 47 ou 48 euros le
mégawattheure ce qui est beaucoup moins
cher évidemment que les prix actuels de
marché le et je le rappelle aussi nous
avons fait cela dans l'intérêt de l'État
puisque ce prix il est garanti aux
producteurs mais lorsque le producteur
le vend sur le marché a un prix
supérieur parce que le marché est à la
hausse c'est l'État qui récupère la
différence et on a vu que ces recettes
ont été très importantes en 2022 pour
financer notamment le bouclier énergie
je rappelle que nous avons continué à
développer les interconnexions j'ai
moi-même signé un accord avec les
Irlandais à Cork au printemps 2019 avec
d'ailleurs François Brotte en tant que
président de RTE à l'époque
je veux aussi dire parce que je sais que
c'est important par rapport dans le
environnement on va dire politique ou
médiatique de votre commission que pour
ma part ce qu'on dit quel était votre
état d'esprit comment vous avez abordé
votre mission à l'époque je me suis
exprimé donc ces vérifiables interview
dans le monde le 10 septembre 2018 je
suis nommé de mémoire 4 moins d'une
semaine après j'accepte une interview
pour poser les choses le monde titre il
faut sortir de la guerre de religion sur
le nucléaire l'interview ne porte pas
que là-dessus mais il y a plusieurs
passages et je dis notamment il est
l'important est de savoir quels sont les
données économiques dans le nucléaire et
dans le domaine des énergies
renouvelables de savoir aussi quels sont
les données en matière de sûreté je n'ai
rien à enlever pour ma part à mes propos
de 2018 et je n'ai pas de trop de
mémoire en la matière et le lors du
discours de la présentation de la PPE de
la programmation plus rien de énergie
nous allons dans le même puissance
puisque nous disons et nous expliquons
que si des réacteurs enfin que les
réacteurs seront fermés en fonction des
données de sûreté et de ce qui sera dit
par l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire et
non pas dans une logique de symbole de
dire on ferme une Centrale qui
simplement pour fermer des centrales et
je crois d'ailleurs que l'énergie comme
bien d'autres domaines politiques
souffre bien souvent que l'on préfère
débattre si on peut dire autour des
symboles que autour des réalités mais
les réalités ont fini toujours par être
rattrapé évidemment par elle en 2019 le
28 janvier est présenté le contraste
stratégique de filière nucléaire
et je redis à ce moment là que dans la
feuille de route cité par la presse
publique dans la feuille de route
énergétique de la France le nucléaire
joue un rôle important et je crois
pouvoir dire évidemment vous ne pourrez
pas auditionner le président de la
République en fonction mais je crois
pouvoir dire que le Président de la
République pendant les 5 ans de son
premier mandat a fait ce qu'il avait dit
y compris en disant que dans la
programmation pure anale énergie il est
dit que s'il y avait des commandes de
nouveaux réacteurs de type EPR cela
serait fait après les élections de 2022
il l'a dit dans un discours à Belfort au
début de l'année 2022 il y a un an
environ et c'est quelque chose qui a été
évidemment préparé et qui est
aujourd'hui possible et d'ailleurs le
Parlement a je crois à en débattre voilà
ce que je voulais dire en propos
introductif et je me tiens bien sûr à
votre disposition pour les questions
pour répondre à des questions pardon
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
alors évidemment dans toujours eu
beaucoup de questions dans notre
commission d'enquête donc on ne fera pas
exception ce soir
vous succédez à Nicolas Hulot qui vous a
précédé à cette place il y a quelques
jours et finalement ça m'inspire une
première question
en tant que ministre sur la place de
l'expertise au sein au sein du ministère
de l'Environnement et le rapport à
l'expertise
on a beaucoup parlé
avec Nicolas Hulot du rapport collés
sans parler du fond
on a sûrement été très surpris de
du dialogue qui s'est passé y compris
ici sur la place de l'expertise
vous avez je crois une même directrice
de cabinet Nicolas Hulot
pendant 2 mois changer après
comment s'est construit pour vous ce
rapport ce dialogue entre expert
politique
espace de d'intermédiation entre
expertise et politique au sein au sein
du ministère
je vous remercie monsieur le Président
de poser cette question parce que j'ai
vu comme certains qui ont suivi les
débats de les auditions de cette
commission j'ai vu un certain nombre de
choses j'ai lu aussi des comptes rendus
j'avoue que quand je vois qu'une haute
personnalité monsieur Brechet parce que
moi je veux pas tourner autour du pot
dit dans son audition à propos des
conseillers mais en cause les
conseillers dans les cabinets
ministériels et les ministres ils sont
censés conseiller je cite sur des sujets
qui ne maîtrisent généralement pas un
ministre qui ne se pose même pas la
question
et un autre moment il dit un zozo dont
j'ai oublié le nom bon ce qui montre
quand même la rigueur du propos alors on
pourrait dire tout ce qui a été excessif
est insignifiant un grand auteur l'a dit
avant moi bien sûr
je voudrais dire que en ce qui me
concerne je ne vais pas parler pour les
autres ministres j'ai évidemment ça me
paraît normal passer énormément de temps
dans des réunions internes dans mon
bureau de ministre des réunions
interministérielles sous la présidence
du Premier ministre du président de la
République il y a des instances je crois
que vous avez posé la question
d'ailleurs aussi sur la réunion de
certaines instances le Conseil de
politique nucléaire différentes
instances par exemple sur le nucléaire
nous avons évidemment eu énormément de
réunions sur les arbitrages pour la
programmation pluriannuelle de l'énergie
les choix que nous devions faire des
discussions parfois âpres entre
ministres c'est normal et évidemment
appuyer sur des données techniques et
économiques fournies par les services du
ministère il y a au ministère de
l'écologie la direction générale de
l'énergie et du climat
qui était autrefois d'ailleurs à Bercy
et qui était rattachée au ministère de
l'Énergie lorsque celui-ci existait pas
toujours existé dans tous les
gouvernements mais depuis 2007 depuis
que Nicolas Sarkozy a été élu président
de la République il a fait le choix je
crois que c'est un bon choix d'ailleurs
de regrouper au sein d'un grand
ministère de l'écologie ces différentes
fonctions et donc la direction générale
de l'énergie et du climat est au sein du
ministère de l'écologie il y a bien sûr
si on parle du nucléaire Commissariat à
l'énergie atomique il y a RTE
réseau de transport de l'électricité est
en France la source d'expertise pour
savoir comment on peut assurer le bon
fonctionnement du système électrique et
la sécurité d'approvisionnement sont
deux sujets un petit peu différents mais
qui à la fin permettent aux Français
d'avoir accès à l'électricité donc
évidemment j'ai également tout à fait
normal c'est énormément de temps avec le
président de RTL et ses équipes avec le
président d'EDF et ses équipes avec le
président dorano avec le
CEA bien sûr tout cela est tout à fait
normal mais je ne peux pas laisser dire
que des ministres en tout cas moi
peut-être avant après moi moi je n'en
ferai pas en tout cas le procès mais se
prendrait des décisions sans se
préoccuper de l'expertise technique
scientifique économique ce qu'on ne peut
pas non plus faire comme si l'économie
les prix les coûts ça n'existait pas
pourquoi je dis cela parce qu'à la fin
ce sont les Français qui payent dans
leur facture d'électricité si on parle
de l'électricité vous allez faire
référence au mouvement des gilets jaunes
on se souvient à l'époque de l'extrême
sensibilité sur la question et c'est
bien normal des prix de l'énergie déjà à
l'époque je veux dire aussi que pour ma
part j'ai pu constater et c'est assez
logique quand on regarde l'histoire de
France que la plupart des dirigeants
politiques
la plupart des dirigeants de toutes ces
instances les entreprises concernées
sont pro nucléaires
je n'ai jamais vu un dirigeant de DF
anti-nucléaire je n'ai jamais vu je vous
rappelle les Français ne le savent sans
doute pas que dans les réunions
interministérielles il y a le Ministère
de la Recherche comme moi quand j'étais
ministre la ministre ne s'en cachait pas
été pro nucléaire le ministre de
l'économie pour nucléaire le ministre de
la Défense
en nucléaire le ministre d'affaires
étrangères parfois car il y a des
notions qui évidemment concernent aussi
la diplomatie française donc je crois
qu'il faut il vaut mieux tout de suite
sortir de ce faux débat sur il y aurait
les bons et les méchants les
incompétents qui seraient les politiques
et les gentils compétents qui seraient
les experts les scientifiques les hauts
commissaires bon qui peuvent d'autant
plus s'exprimer y compris devant vous
qui non de compte à rendre à personne
pendant toute leur carrière
professionnelle autrement qu'à leur
supérieure éventuellement et encore
parce que parfois ce sont des autorités
indépendantes mais en tout cas n'ont pas
de compte à rendre aux citoyens citoyens
qui sont aussi des électeurs qui sont
aussi des consommateurs et qui payent
soit par le biais de leur facture soit
par leur biais de leurs impôts je veux
quand même le rappeler c'est normal
quand on est politique on rendait compte
et on rend compte d'abord et avant tout
aux citoyens et au qui sont encore une
fois et des électeurs et des
consommateurs
ma question était pas tant en écho à ce
que je dirige
a pu dire par exemple cette ancienne
directrice de cabinet qui dit on a eu le
rapport colibillons on a considéré que
la réponse ne correspondait pas à la
question qu'on avait posé du coup on l'a
classé en tout cas moi je peux vous dire
que quand j'ai été nommé ministre c'est
avant même que je sois nommé aussi il
faut le dire aux Français c'est pas
parce que c'est des choses qui ne sont
pas publiques qu'on ne peut pas en
parler avant d'être nommé on discute en
tout cas moi j'ai discuté que le
Président de la République avant d'être
nommé avant d'être accepté avant
d'accepter d'être nommé et j'ai discuté
avec lui de ces sujets là et un des
sujets dont nous avons parlé c'est le
rapport d'escata je crois que vous en
avez parlé c'est normal il venait il
avait été rendu avant que je sois nommé
j'étais nommé j'allais pas faire comme
ça n'existait pas et donc ces rapports
comme d'autres comme ceux de RTE comme
ceux du commissariat l'énergie atomique
comme ceux de l'ADEME et alors je le
rappelle la dame est un opérateur de
l'État un peu le bras armé de l'État
prend peut-être son autonomie dans sa
communication mais normalement c'est un
établissement qui agit pour le compte de
l'État bon toutes ces sources là font
partie évidemment des sujets qu'on a sur
la table quand on est ministre avant de
prendre des décisions après on peut
faire le choix de rentrer plus ou moins
dans les dossiers il y a des gens en
politique qui revendiquent de ne pas
rentrer dans l'aspect un peu technique
ou économique ou chiffrée c'est
l'endroit moi je les fais je ne suis pas
devenu ingénieur du nucléaire je n'ai
pas cette prétention mais j'ai pris la
peine évidemment de prendre connaissance
de ces différentes données
alors si on si on reste un peu sur sur
les données j'aimerais qu'on ait un
échange un peu sur les sur les scénarios
on parle beaucoup des scénarios
notamment de RTE sur lesquels le
gouvernement l'État c'est beaucoup
reposé pour pour construire sa stratégie
énergétique
vous avez dit vous même que on parle
finalement beaucoup d'électricité un peu
d'énergie dans son ensemble je pense
notre commission
également traiter les autres sources
d'énergie même si c'est sûr et une
focale particulière c'est l'électricité
c'est du coup surprenant de constater
que ce sont les rapports RTE qui
deviennent
la pierre angulaire de la stratégie
énergétique alors krte elle transporteur
d'électricité et pas d'énergie
alors RTE d'abord au delà de son statut
d'entreprises publiques qui en effet
assure le transport de l'électricité et
de haute tension parce qu'il y a une
indice pour la la basse tension et la
desserte du client final a aussi pour
mission a dans ses missions d'assurer le
bon fonctionnement du réseau électrique
c'est vrai que on va pas rentrer dans
les détails techniques et c'est
malheureux d'ailleurs qu'on ne puisse
pas avoir des de présentation dans les
médias par exemple sur ces choses là qui
soient à la fois
précises et grand public il faut jamais
oublier que l'électricité sa très grande
particularité c'est qu'on ne peut
quasiment pas la stocker
en tout cas pas à grande échelle donc
quand on produit de l'électricité il
faut la consommer tout de suite et donc
c'est un une sorte de combat permanent
il y a des plusieurs milliers de
personnes au sein de RTE dont le travail
est en permanence de veiller à
l'équilibrage du réseau bon donc c'est
normal que on prenne comme référence
pour savoir si un scénario sur les
moyens de production va avoir tel et tel
effet sur le réseau avec par ailleurs
les interconnexions européennes qui ont
une grande utilité et dont la France
d'ailleurs a fortement bénéficié d'abord
en tant qu'exportateur et l'année
dernière pour pouvoir pallier la baisse
de production sur le parc nucléaire mais
je voudrais quand même rappeler parce
que là aussi ce sont des chiffres je
pense pas qu'il soit contesté par qui
que ce soit en 2022 on a eu un taux de
disponibilité de 54%
sur les réacteurs nucléaires
en moyenne dans les 20 dernières années
incluant les années où moi j'étais
ministre on était à plus de 70%. donc
c'est sûr que vous pouvez pas faire un
scénario qui inclut une telle chute de
la production alors que l'opérateur il
n'y en a qu'un cedf vous dit chaque fois
que vous le consultez nous assurerons le
même taux de disponibilité malgré l'âge
qui était connu avancée des réacteurs et
d'ailleurs y compris les discussions
avec les scénarios en question sur la
prolongation de la durée de vie des
centrales on sait quelque chose que vous
avez beaucoup aussi discuté avec les
personnes que vous avez auditionnées
notamment les anciens présidents ou le
président actuel d'EDF et bien
évidemment été fondé sur l'idée que
c'était quelque chose qui n'allait pas
poser de problème majeurs en termes de
capacité à produire ça permettait de
maintenir la même cassette or ça n'a pas
été le cas bon là c'est c'est quelque
chose qui n'avait jamais été envisagé on
ne peut pas en faire le reproche à RTE
puisque c'est effondré sur les données
fournies par EDF par les assurances
fournies par EDF
je rappelle aussi c'est moins connu je
pense que au moins une demande de votre
commission qui elle le connaît très bien
la plus faible disponibilité en 2022 de
l'hydraulique moins 20% par rapport aux
années 2014 à cause de la sécheresse
[Musique]
dans votre propos introductif vous allez
regretté
l'absence de coordination européenne sur
la question de la production
alors je dois vous avouer que bon je
vais un peu sortir de la réserve qui
habituellement la mienne en tant que
présidente de cette commission d'enquête
mais je vous avouer que venant de vous
ça me surprend un peu
parce que finalement vous êtes
je me ramène à ma condition de député de
Fessenheim mais vous êtes ministre en
2018 2019 sur une période où la
fermeture de Fessenheim se prépare et
dans les arguments que
nous opposons à votre ministère à
l'époque pour s'opposer à la fermeture
de Fessenheim il y a la faible
crédibilité des scénarios de
remplacement en matière de réponse à la
au besoin énergétiques de l'Alsace et on
critique notamment la lecture qui est
celle faite par RT et votre ministère de
dire vous en faites pas l'électricité
viendra d'Allemagne et vous nous dites
aujourd'hui ah oui mais on n'a pas de
coordination au niveau européen de la
question de la production on a des
interconnexions en gros on pose un câble
mais on se pose jamais la question de
savoir si de l'autre côté du câble ce
qui est branché sera en mesure de nous
donner ou pas de l'électricité quand
nous nous quand nous en aurons besoin
et puis du coup un peu surpris de cette
contradiction entre les arguments que
vous opposez en tant que ministre à
l'époque sur ce dossier précis et votre
constat aujourd'hui qui est de dire je
regrette que à l'échelle européenne il
n'y ait pas de coordination sur la
question de la production donc je vous
prie de bien vouloir excuser ma petite
sortie de réserve qui n'est pas
habituelle dans le déroulement de cette
commission mais je trouve là qu'on a une
forme de contradiction assez évidente
d'abord on pourrait reprendre les propos
des uns et des autres et nous avons eu
des échanges à l'époque
que ce soit ici à l'Assemblée nationale
ou que ce soit par média interposés ou
même sur le terrain puisque je me suis
rendu bien sûr dans votre région
je ne crois pas avoir dit que c'était
parce que l'Allemagne fournirait la
France à l'époque sur la base des
données fournies par RTS s'appuyant sur
les données fournies par EDF
était en capacité de d'absorber cela
après il y a le fait que les
interconnexions permettent chacun le
sait bien en tout cas quand on
s'intéresse au sujet et c'est votre cas
c'est le cas de évidemment de RTE d'EDF
etc que on peut lisser
grâce aux interconnexions européennes le
fait qu'à certains moments on produit
plus dans tel pays que dans telle autre
en général d'ailleurs c'était au
bénéfice de la France c'est seulement en
2022 qu'il y a eu une situation
d'importation nette mais sinon la France
a toujours été exportatrice nette sur
l'ensemble des années avec ce point que
à certains moments la France bénéficiait
évidemment du surplus d'électricité
produite dans des pays voisins pour
notamment les périodes de pointe en
France et que l'on savait que par
ailleurs nos voisins notamment allemand
bien sûr mais aussi espagnol ou italien
ou même le Royaume-Uni qui est sorti de
l'Union européenne entre temps mais
avait une augmentation de leur capacité
de production renouvelables
le Danemark voilà notre pays donc ça
c'est quelque chose qui par ailleurs
était une donnée fondamentale puisque
évidemment ses capacités là elles sont
durables mais ce que j'ai voulu dire
quand j'ai dit le manque de coordination
sur la production c'est sur les
décisions sur un certain nombre de choix
on le sait bien l'Allemagne a fait
cavalier seul sur la sortie du nucléaire
et la France par fait ses choix aussi
sans demander évidemment leur avis aux
voisins au passage je vous le dis pas à
vous en tant que personne mais à la
commission aux membres de la commission
quand j'étais ministre j'ai eu beaucoup
d'échanges avec les Allemands
normal la relation franco-allemande un
sujet majeur le président de la
République m'avait demandé je ne
travaille pas de secret en disant cela
m'avait demandé
d'aller voir mes homologues allemands
pour leur proposer de leur vendre
davantage d'électricité des carbonée
donc nucléaire en France pour qu'il
puisse sortir plus vite du charbon les
Allemands ont répondu de façon négative
de façon extrêmement ferme je rappelle
qu'à l'époque c'est un gouvernement
conservateur avec Madame Merkel
chancelière d'Allemagne et
fédéralt Maya qui était ministre à la
fois de l'économie et de l'énergie et
leur demande puisque monsieur Altmayer
par ailleurs est un élu de la Sarre
était de savoir quand est-ce que nous
fermerions la centrale de 4 nonnes
en plus celle de Fessenheim ça ne leur
suffisait pas du tout et les
Luxembourgeois le Premier ministre du
Luxembourg demandait également quand
est-ce que nous allions fermer la
centrale de Cattenom car il s'estimé mis
en danger par la centrale nucléaire
française de Cattenom en Lorraine voilà
il faut quand même redire tout cela
parce que sinon on parle un peu en
dehors des réalités
alors 2019 si je ne m'abuse c'est aussi
la date
nous l'abandons de la Missou coco du
projet Astrid
c'est une décision interministérielle
quel est le la position que portait à
l'époque le ministère de l'écologie au
regard de sa compétence notamment en
matière de sûreté de cycle du
combustible et de déchets
il y a eu en effet une réunion
interministérielle sous la présidence du
Premier ministre
et qui a dit en effet clairement que
comme on dit parfois trivialement on
arrête les frais mais c'est au sens
propre du terme sur le projet Astrid
dans la mesure où il n'avait pas
démontré sa capacité à se transformer en
projet concret
mature technologiquement et
financièrement soutenable il y avait une
demande de remettre de l'argent et en
effet nous avons décidé de ne pas
remettre de l'argent et c'était une
décision qui était assez consensuelle
autour de la de la table des acteurs de
cette réunion intermittiale donc comme
son nom l'indique nous représentions
différents ministères ou bien sur le CEA
était représenté bien sûr souhaitait
poursuivre il faut le dire aussi et que
nous n'avons pas donné suite je rappelle
aussi que c'était un projet
international
et que les partenaires internationaux de
la France n'étaient pas au rendez-vous
pour remettre de l'argent dans ce projet
voilà c'est du coup est-ce que vous
aviez à l'occasion de cette réunion
interministérielle connaissance de la
proposition de l'administrateur général
du CEA de l'époque de
non pas à construire Astrid comme
réacteur de 1600 mégawatts mais de
construire un démonstrateur de moindre
taille autour de 200 MW pour maintenir
la compétence pour suivre la recherche
et avancer dans la possibilité des de
concrétiser ce projet
oui c'était justement je pense l'objet
de la demande qui était de mettre de
l'argent dans ce projet et le Premier
ministre arbitré dans le sens de ne pas
le faire le premier ministre qui je le
rappelle n'est absolument pas
anti-nucléaire ne l'a jamais été a
toujours revendiqué le fait d'avoir même
travaillé dans une entreprise française
du nucléaire et d'être de croire en
l'énergie nucléaire donc je vois qu'il
faut quand même être bien clair sur le
contexte les lieux où se prennent les
décisions et les processus de décision
ce ne sont pas des décisions qui se
prennent à la légère c'est après des
années et des années de tentatives
divers et variées qui n'ont pas marché
et qui ont coûté de l'argent
et c'est avec de l'argent de l'État
c'est pas la facture d'électricité des
Français pour le coup si on voulait
intégrer cela en disant c'est absolument
vital dans la filière nucléaire d'une
manière générale donc dans la production
d'électricité il faudrait à ce moment-là
en intégrer le coût dans la facture
d'électricité des Français il faut quand
même le rappeler
donc d'ailleurs au passage je rappelle
que la précédente commission d'enquête à
laquelle je faisais références en 2014
président
elle avait chiffré enfin la Cour des
comptes à sa demande avait chiffré le
grand carénage des centrales nucléaires
si on voulait les prolonger à 100
milliards d'euros un chiffre de la Cour
des comptes à l'époque fournit à
l'Assemblée à sa demande voilà c'est
toutes ces choses là on peut pas les
perdre de vue on pourrait aussi parler
des dérives de coûts qui sont d'ailleurs
difficiles à évaluer sur le père de
Flamanville
évidemment qu'il faut que le père de
Flamanville soit mis en service un jour
et qu'il produisent de l'électricité
contrairement à ce que j'entends parfois
c'est absolument délirant j'entends des
gens qui disent bah il faut arrêter
non ça a déjà coûté très très cher donc
il faut absolument que ça produise de
l'électricité mais ce n'est toujours pas
le cas dans la loi de 2005 à laquelle je
faisais référence tout à l'heure il
était dit que cela devait le nous le
réacteur de nouvelle génération devait
être mis en service à l'horizon en 2015
quand j'ai été réélu député vous avez
fait mention en 2012 on m'a demandé si
je pensais que si j'étais un jour
ministre de l'écologie j'irai inauguré
le père de Flamanville jeudi je suis pas
sûr qu'on y arrive entre 2012 et 2017
oui mais si mais si bien sûr en 2017 on
nous a redit ça va se produire ce n'est
toujours pas le cas moi je le regrette
d'ailleurs et je peux vous dire que nous
avons eu des discussions vous parliez de
l'expertise très ardu avec EDF sur ce
sujet d'abord ce que nous avions du mal
à savoir ce qu'il en était vraiment
et que l'on découvrait des problèmes au
fil du temps
et donc des surcoûts et donc des délais
supplémentaires que l'Autorité de sûreté
du nucléaire c'est elle qui donne la vie
qui permet ou pas de mettre en service
EDF aurait aimé que l'on passe outre et
en effet nous avons dit non c'est
l'autorité de sûreté du nucléaire qui
est une autorité indépendante qui prend
cette décision je crois qu'il faut quand
même dire aussi moi je le regrette
d'ailleurs mais que la filière nucléaire
française civile je parle pas du
militaire
ces dernières années a subi un certain
nombre de difficultés pour pas dire
d'échec qui ont fini par mettre en cause
sa crédibilité et notamment vous parlez
de la souveraineté et notamment à
l'export c'était évident que cela nous
fragilise à l'export et c'est tout à
fait dommageable et honnêtement avec des
présidents de la République successifs
qui ont soutenu le président Sarkozy a
soutenu l'export il a souhaité à
l'époque regrouper EDF et arriva pour
que il n'y ait plus assez frictions
c'est concurrence ces oppositions qu'on
trouvait avec le fait que ce n'était pas
EDF qui avait fait le chantier pr en
Finlande mais Areva etc ça n'a
malheureusement pas suffi le président
Hollande a soutenu son
ses ministres également et le président
Macron également et malheureusement à
part inclipoint et espérons que ça
marche bien inclipoint ça n'a pas pu se
traduire
un peu loin de la question sur Astrid
parce que c'est dans un contexte c'est
dans un contexte où il y avait un
certain nombre de dérives techniques et
budgétaires avec un grand carénage qui
aujourd'hui s'approche plutôt des 50
milliards que des 100 milliards chiffrés
par François Brotte en 2015 par la Cour
des comptes
dans le cadre des travaux menés par
ancien collègue
vous avez dit dans votre propos
introductif que le sujet finalement
corroborer un peu ce qui a été déjà été
dit dans cette commission
la question de la reine avant 2018 quand
le prix de l'électricité inter inférieur
à 42 euros n'était pas un sujet mais
qu'en 2018 ça a commencé à monter
ça dépasse 50 euros est-ce que ça
devient un sujet à ce moment là et quels
sont les alertes que vous réceptionnez
au comme on l'appelle MTES à l'époque
non non oui oui vous avez raison
ministre de la transition écologique et
solidaire personnellement j'aurais
préféré d'ailleurs qui s'appelle
ministre ministère de l'Écologie de
l'Énergie
de l'environnement et de la mer puisque
c'était ça ses compétences mais passons
sur le la reine alors c'est vrai que
c'est quelque chose qui est très abscon
pour les Français qui a été voté en 2010
et qui
doit s'arrêter en 2025 pour 15 ans donc
je le dis quand même puisqu'on parle de
quelque chose qui va s'éteindre de toute
façon d'ici trois ans deux ans
en l'occurrence EDF à demander en tout
cas moi j'étais ministre que le prix de
la reine soit relevé considérant qu'un
prix à 42 euros ne couvrait pas les
coûts de production
ce prix n'a pas été fixé par hasard il
faut quand même le rappeler à une époque
on disait le prix le coût de production
de l'électricité nucléaire en France est
inférieure à 40 euros et donc on est à
42 euros ça permet de couvrir les coûts
et même quelques investissements de pour
la maintenance mais EDF a dit je pense
que c'était tout à fait légitime que ça
ne couvrait plus les coûts et donc il
serait légitime de le relever j'y étais
favorable je pense d'ailleurs que
il aurait sans doute fallu discuter d'un
relèvement entre 48 et 52 euros ce qui
est évidemment à une conséquence sur les
prix de l'électricité il fallait
évidemment le négocier avec la
Commission européenne puisque c'est un
mécanisme qui est issu d'un compromis
entre la France et l'Europe qui était
d'ouvrir à la concurrence tout en
maintenant tout le parc nucléaire dans
une seule société EDF ce qui est par
ailleurs une bonne chose à mon sens mais
du coup pour avoir des moyens de
production disponibles pour les nouveaux
entrants je rappelle aussi parce qu'on
entend tout et n'importe quoi notamment
de la part de syndicalistes de DF que en
l'occurrence la reine c'est sans
térawattheure sur une production
nucléaire de plus de 350 et que c'est
passé à 120 en 2022 avec un prix qui a
été mieux rémunéré c'est-à-dire que EDF
a dû en vendre 120 mais à un prix qui
est de 46 euros 50
et en l'occurrence c'est ce qui à la fin
se retrouve dans le prix de
l'électricité des Français à l'époque
quand moi j'étais ministre j'ai dû faire
face à une situation très tendue sur les
prix de l'électricité puisque en effet
après le mouvement des gilets jaunes et
les tensions sur les prix des carburants
ce qui se comprend tout à fait la
sensibilité au prix des carburants prix
du fioul aussi ou et du gaz pour le
chauffage et bien on avait les prix de
l'électricité qui devaient augmenter
sur une année de 7 8%
. nous avons décidé que le premier
ministre de différer cette hausse et moi
j'ai proposé au gouvernement que l'on
change le mode de calcul qui a mené à ce
tarif c'est ce qui a été fait dans la
loi de 2019 cela m'a été reproché à
l'époque
par EDF par des syndicalistes d'EDF par
certains médias qui se sont empressés de
dire que c'était pour favoriser les
concurrents ce qui était totalement faux
c'était pour favoriser les français pour
maîtriser le prix et d'ailleurs le
gouvernement après quand moi j'ai quitté
le gouvernement ne l'a pas activé tout
de suite mais il l'a activé en 2022 et
il a été bien content que la loi ait été
changée en 2019 pour que ça puisse être
activé en 2022 et contenir une hausse
qui était là encore beaucoup plus forte
je pense qu'évidemment ce mécanisme doit
être révisé à terme d'ailleurs il va il
va disparaître mais il y a beaucoup de
choses qui sont dites sur le sujet qui
sont qui ne correspondent pas à la
réalité en 2022 pourquoi ça a été si
problématique pour EDF parce que entre
temps la production c'était effondrée
bien sûr
bien quand vous arrivez
vous l'avez dit vous-même vous discutez
donc avec le président de la République
notamment des enjeux du rapport des
scatabilons ce que vous l'avez c'est
vous qui l'avez dit tous les enjeux
autour de l'énergie qui
on l'a compris au fil des auditions dans
les grandes lignes
conclu que pour maintenir les
compétences et redévelopper les
compétences de la filière
électronucléaire française il ne faut
pas seulement des plans de formation il
faut aussi des objets de travail et donc
la construction
d'un programme de nouveaux nucléaire
néanmoins vous avez précisé que cette
décision a un reportée
à la fin de la législature est-ce que
c'est une décision que vous construisez
avec avec Matignon avec l'Elysée ou
est-ce que c'est quelque chose que vous
mettez en œuvre
d'abord vous imaginez bien qu'un
ministre même numéro 2 du gouvernement
comme je l'étais ne prend pas des
décisions tout seul
non seulement ça des sujets de c'est
important mais même parfois sur des
sujets de bien moindre importance mais
c'est normal un gouvernement c'est pas
c'est pas une équipe d'individualité
c'est un collectif sous la direction
d'un Premier ministre et sous l'autorité
d'un président qui je le rappelle c'est
la Constitution nomme et met fin aux
fonctions des ministres bon donc il est
tout à fait normal que ces sujets là
soient discutés et soit arbitré en
l'occurrence c'est un choix qui est
assez logique
le Pr en 2017 quand Emmanuel Macron
était élu moi quand je suis nommé
ministre en 2018 quand je quitte le
gouvernement en 2019 mais même l'année
dernière en 2022 quand ont lieu les
élections présidentielles et
législatives le Pr n'est toujours pas en
fonctionnement
et ne produit toujours pas d'électricité
c'est donc quelque chose qui est un peu
problématique dans la présentation du
contrat de filière nucléaire que nous
faisons avec le ministre de l'Économie
Bruno Le Maire en janvier 2019 Bruno Le
Maire dit comme moi il faut d'abord que
voilà vous voyez c'est j'ai repris
l'extrait de l'article le ministre de
l'Économie Bruno Le Maire lui préciser
qu'il relève de la sagesse d'attendre
que Flamanville et fait la preuve de son
fonctionnement avant d'engager des
décisions sur le nouveau nucléaire
voilà donc c'est quelque chose qui était
à l'époque partagé et assez logique je
sais alors ils sont pas là mais qu'il y
a des membres de votre commission en
tout cas des membres de l'Assemblée tout
à fait normal qui représentent des
courants d'opinion qui considère que ces
problèmes condamnent définitivement la
filière européenne que plus jamais il ne
faut construire de paires il y a même
des gens dans la filière nucléaire qui
pensent qu'il vaut mieux développer soit
le nucléaire classique
soit donc revenir à des réacteurs plus
proches de ceux qu'on avait dans les
générations précédentes soit du petit
nucléaire tout le monde ne met pas la
même chose derrière le petit les fameux
Smalls modular reactor mais à l'époque
la France dit gouvernement français
auquel j'appartiens dit on va demander
EDF de mener à bien le chantier bien sûr
de perdre pour qu'il produisent
l'électricité et ensuite on lui
demandera d'ailleurs ma successeur
Elisabeth borne a cossigné un courrier
Bruno Le Maire au mois de septembre 2019
pour demander à EDF quel serait les
conditions pour commander je crois trois
pairs 6 réacteurs de type EPR est allé
dans le temps et pour que le
gouvernement soit éclairé sur les
conditions d'un tel choix et ensuite
éclairer les Français et en l'occurrence
qui ont pu en débattre au moment de
l'élection présidentielle et des
élections législatives
bien j'ai une dernière question
qui est relève finalement de plusieurs
auditions qu'on a eu également qui est
un peu plus prospective
on a entendu notamment Nathalie
Kosciusko-Morizet qui nous a expliqué la
démarche du Grenelle de l'environnement
et la façon dont elle a souhaité mettre
autour de table des acteurs de
l'environnement et des ONG qui n'étaient
pas jusque là institutionnellement pris
en compte par
le ministère on a entendu également les
représentants des syndicats du ministère
de de l'énergie plutôt pas du ministère
mais les branches énergies des syndicats
qui nous ont expliqué que
ça devenait être difficile pour eux
d'être sur les mêmes tours de table dans
des logiques ou eux d'un côté doivent
faire preuve de représentativité eu
égard aux règles finalement du code du
travail et de la loi 2010 notamment
alors que de l'autre côté de la table se
trouve des ONG dont la présence ne
relève d'aucune forme de construction de
de légitimité publique comment est-ce
que vous analysez cela aujourd'hui eu
égard finalement depuis le Grenelle de
l'environnement à l'expérience acquise
d'abord il faut quand même rappeler
qu'au Grenelle de l'environnement les
sujets énergies avaient été exclus du
champ et du champ de
nucléaire du champ du Grenelle de
l'environnement c'était le choix du
président Sarkozy à l'époque moi j'y ai
participé en tant que député Grenelle
j'ai fait partie des quelques députés
qui ont pu être autour de la table
c'était une expérience d'ailleurs très
enrichissante
intéressantes qui a débouché sur
plusieurs lois donc avec des effets
concrets quand moi j'étais ministre je
pense que ça a été pareil après moi vous
savez il y a jamais de décision qui sont
prises en ayant mis autour de la même
table des représentants d'ONG des
représentants de syndicats ou autre le
connaît c'était quelque chose avant de
particulier qui n'est pas renouvelé sous
la même forme et qui de toute façon
proposait un certain nombre de choses et
ensuite le gouvernement et le Parlement
prenait leur décision mais en tout cas
quand moi je démise j'ai jamais mis sur
le même plan
les responsables politiques les
responsables techniques et économiques
de l'énergie
les syndicats et les
ONG donc ça c'est clair et net alors ça
ne veut pas dire que les uns les autres
ne sont pas légitimes à exprimer des
points de vue mais moi je considère que
ce ne doit évidemment pas sous-traiter
la décision par ailleurs je le dis ça a
été publique à ce moment-là donc
c'est quelque chose qui est facilement
vérifiable moi je me suis opposé à
plusieurs reprises à certaines ONG comme
gagnepiste par exemple qui a fait un
lobbying intense avec des campagnes
médiatiques avec des coups d'éclat dont
ils ont le secret contre le nucléaire
mais qui n'a jamais rien dit contre les
centrales thermiques et qui d'ailleurs
n'a jamais salué le fait que nous ayons
annoncé la fermeture des centrales à
charbon et je crois que ça dit beaucoup
de choses sur le fait que sous couvert
de vouloir agir pour le climat en fait
il y a d'autres buts qui sont poursuivis
qui sont un peu des symboles qui sont un
peu des totems voire peut-être de
l'idéologie je ne sais pas par rapport
au nucléaire quand moi j'ai dit
dans le en septembre 2018 j'aimerais
qu'on sorte de la guerre de religion sur
le nucléaire bon elle existe toujours
cette guerre de religion malheureusement
je pense que c'est dommage je je note en
revanche avec un intérêt que le climat
politique dans l'opinion a changé depuis
deux trois ans et que aujourd'hui en
France on oppose plus systématiquement
nucléaire énergie nucléaire et écologie
quand moi j'étais ministre des
journalistes me reprenaient dans des
interviews pour me dire vous ne pouvez
pas faire de l'écologie si en même temps
vous faites du nucléaire bon je
considère que pour le climat je l'ai dit
je l'ai écrit d'ailleurs y compris après
lorsque j'avais quitté le ministère j'ai
d'ailleurs évolué sur le sujet et je
l'assume totalement que le nucléaire est
une contribution importante pour relever
le défi climatique et que pour avoir une
énergie décarbonée le choix qui a été
fait de fait entre lequel j'ai participé
entre 2017 2022 c'est un choix qui
consiste à avoir à la fois un
développement des renouvelables et
également un maintien et un
renouvellement du nucléaire je profite
pour le dire parce que c'est quelque
chose qui est peu dit c'est assez
original dans le monde
dans tous les pays du monde y compris
nos voisins européens quand on développe
fortement le nucléaire regardez le Japon
par exemple on a beaucoup de centrales
thermiques à côté pour faire la pointe
et dans beaucoup d'autres pays où on
développe très fortement le renouvelable
on a beaucoup de centrales thermiques à
côté pour faire face à l'intermittence
de du renouvelable
faute de moyens de stockage de grande
échelle pour l'instant et donc nous en
France
il le choix a été fait il doit être
confirmé d'ailleurs je pense dans les
prochains débats parlementaires par des
lois de développer les renouvelables et
le nucléaire pour que l'un et l'autre se
complètent avec les interconnexions
européennes pour éviter d'avoir recours
au thermique sachant qu'il est déjà
aujourd'hui très modeste
merci monsieur le rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre pour pour votre présence pour
vos explications et les premières
réponses aux questions du président qui
ont été à la fois claires et complète et
donc j'en ai assez peu pour ma part
quelques-unes cependant vous étiez
député
entre 2012 et 2017 et sauf erreur vous
avez voté pour la loi 2015
pourquoi sur quelle base qu'est-ce qui
vous a fait que vous avez décidé de
voter pour cette loi
oui non seulement j'ai voté pour cette
loi j'ai travaillé dessus je suis
intervenu à de nombreuses reprises dans
le débat parlementaire y compris
d'ailleurs dans les débats qui ont pu
enfin oui les discussions qui ont pu
précéder avec les ministres avec le
président de la République François
Hollande je peux témoigner puisque je
connaissais déjà François Hollande avant
qu'il soit élu président de la
République nous étions collègues députés
ici à l'Assemblée nationale j'en avais
parlé avec lui qu'il avait fait cette
proposition
du 50/50
de façon assez symbolique
c'est à dire que ça n'était pas un
calcul savant c'est clair c'était l'idée
voilà on va développer en France quelque
chose qui ne sera plus à aussi forte
dominante nucléaire je rappelle que
quand il a été élu c'était environ 75 %
de la production d'électricité pas
d'énergie mais d'électricité qui était
produite par des centrales nucléaires
que les énergies renouvelables ont
l'hydroélectricité a toujours représenté
bon emballant un peu plus de 10%
le reste les énergies renouvelables
étaient très faibles
donc il a fait ce choix pour des raisons
aussi d'accord politique avec le parti
Europe Écologie Les Verts auquel j'ai
appartenu mais je l'ai quitté en août
2015 je tiens aussi à le préciser et en
l'occurrence
ce n'était pas d'ailleurs contrairement
à ce qui est souvent dit dans les médias
un accord entre le Parti socialiste et
les Verts puisque madame Aubry qui était
chef du Parti socialiste elle avait
négocié un accord avec les verres qui un
allait vers la sortie du nucléaire
qui voulait engager la France dans la
sortie du nucléaire et si Madame Aubry
avait été désigné par les ceux qui ont
participé à la primaire des socialistes
de l'époque elle aurait engagé une loi
de sortie du nucléaire
et ce n'est pas madame Aubry qui a été
désigné c'est Monsieur Hollande et
Monsieur Hollande a dit non moi je ne
suis pas pour la sortie nucléaire
François Hollande n'a jamais été
anti-nucléaire il a toujours pensé que
le nucléaire avait évidemment son
importance mais que on pouvait en
réduire la part par un développement des
énergies renouvelables et non pas des
énergies thermiques bien sûr pas de la
production d'électricité par les
centrales au charbon au fioul ou au gaz
et à partir de là il faut reconnaître
que la loi donc il l'avait promise en
2012 elle a été votée à l'été 2015 trois
ans on peut pas dire que ce soit un
empressement particulier et elle n'a pas
véritablement été appliquée sous son
quinquennat en 2017 les choses n'avaient
pas beaucoup changé en termes de
proportion de production d'électricité
nucléaire moi je l'ai soutenu à l'époque
parce que je pense que en effet c'est
l'intérêt de la France
de construire une production
d'électricité qui soit où on ne passe
pas à côté du fort développement des
énergies renouvelables qui est un fort
développement partout dans le monde
et qui est de baisse des coûts de
production d'ailleurs de l'électricité
par le renouvelable et qui en même temps
ne
n'engage pas la France dans la sortie du
nucléaire Emmanuel Macron a repris sa
sous une autre forme et a notamment et
je l'ai acté avec lui constaté que
c'était totalement irréaliste en 2025
sachant que je crois d'ailleurs je me
permets cette remarque en tant
qu'enseigne député puisque vous faites
référence au fait que j'étais député
déjà à l'époque que l'on gagnerait à ne
plus mettre dans les lois les objectifs
chiffrés une loi n'est pas là pour moi
c'est un point de vue que je défendais
déjà dans mes dernières années de mandat
n'est pas là pour mettre des objectifs
chiffrés on se fait plaisir à dire on va
réduire les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre de tente pour cent en le mettant
dans la loi alors que ce n'est pas
mettre un chiffre qui a de la portée
concrète pour la France pour des
filières économiques industrielles pour
les Français à la fin qui
ont droit à avoir la sécurité
d'approvisionnement d'électricité à
avoir l'électricité un prix aussi
raisonnable que possible et bien cela on
ne le fait pas en mettant des chiffres
dans la Loire on le fait en développant
des moyens et je crois que c'est ce que
nous avons davantage fait ces dernières
années nous avons eu raison de le faire
notamment développant très fortement
l'éolien en mer l'éolien offshore et je
crois d'ailleurs que le Parlement est
appelé a été appelé à aller encore plus
loin dans ce sens ces derniers mois
je reste sur cette question parce que
dans de nombreuses auditions c'est poser
la question de l'information du
Parlement
légiférer de manière éclairée
et justement en tant que parlementaire
alors très
familiarisé aux questions
environnementales avec une experte etc
mais comment est-ce que vous
qualifieriez le niveau d'information
qu'a eu le Parlement quand il a décidé
de cette loi
dont on nous dit à posteriori qu'il
s'agissait d'objectifs politiques et
symbolique et que bien sûr il était tout
à fait entendu qu'il ne s'agissait pas
de se fixer un terme absolument exact de
2025 et de 50% mais quand on regarde les
débats de l'époque c'était quand même
assez clair que 2025 était un objectif
et que 50% c'était pas au point de
pourtant sage au point de pourcentage
près mais c'était globalement un
objectif assez visible et en même temps
les administrations qu'on a pu
interroger de l'époque nous ont dit que
il allait de soi que c'était un objectif
qu'on allait décaler le plus vite
possible puisque il était pas tenable à
cette année là ce qui m'intéresse savoir
c'est les députés de l'époque quelles
informations avaient-ils accès et de ce
fait rétrospectivement quelles
informations sont nécessaires et
aujourd'hui pas disponibles à votre sens
pour les parlementaires au parlementaire
d'abord sur l'énergie mais sur la
production d'électricité
si on prend un peu de recul
et qu'on regarde ne serait-ce que tout
ce qui s'est fait depuis l'après-guerre
ou même sous la Cinquième République si
on veut
objectivement on débat beaucoup plus à
l'Assemblée nationale de tous ces sujets
qu'on ne l'a fait dans les années
50-60 70 ou même 80 il n'y avait pas de
loi pour lancer le programme
électronucléaire français il n'y a pas
eu de loi
peut-être que certains d'ailleurs rêvent
aussi parce que vous vous posez la
question de comment les députés sont
éclairés informés mais je pense qu'il y
a aussi d'autres gens qui rêveraient de
revenir à ces temps anciens où on ne
parlait pas de ces choses au Parlement
et moi je le dis aussi en tant
qu'enseigne ministre ou il y avait une
forme d'État dans l'état et oui compris
les ministres n'étaient pas forcément
informés de façon fiable honnête de
bonne foi par un certain nombre
d'acteurs qui se considéraient comme
pouvant agir en propre sans avoir de
rendre un compte au décideurs politiques
et je pense qu'une partie des problèmes
actuels vient de là d'ailleurs je me
permets de le dire au passage parce que
je pense que c'est un sujet assez
important pour les Français qui a des
conséquences très concrètes je rappelle
quand même que les difficultés d'ef ne
se limitent pas à la question de le père
de Flamanville ou des la maintenance des
réacteurs des 56 réacteurs existants je
suis quand même déjà quelque chose
d'assez important mais aussi à sa
situation financière
mais il faut aussi assumer politiquement
au passage je le dis cohérent
politiquement que tout cela a un prix et
qu'à la fin c'est dans le prix de
l'électricité après sur le verre à
moitié vide il y a aussi
la question plus générale de
est-ce que quand on prend des lois on
fait un travail préalable d'évaluation
de la situation
ce n'est pas la tradition des
institutions françaises et ce n'est pas
la tradition du Parlement français je le
regrette quand j'étais président de
l'Assemblée nationale j'ai voulu
développer le fait que l'Assemblée
nationale se dote d'un véritable organe
d'évaluation mais pas dans le sens où on
l'entend souvent on dit on va évaluer la
loi une fois qu'elle est votée
de voter des lois
et je pense que de ce point de vue là le
travail de votre commission est très
utile il y a d'autres débats en
parallèle donc évidemment c'est pas mais
quand même ça peut nourrir les décisions
qui vont être prises dans les mois ou
les années qui viennent alors il y avait
eu une commission en 2014 elle était de
centrée sur le coup du nucléaire donc
c'est vrai que c'était sur un seul sujet
ça moi je crois que ce serait quelque
chose c'est un changement culturel parce
que en France dans le débat politique on
préfère toujours ce chamailler on va
dire ce mot un peu enfantin qui est un
euphémisme
sur ce que l'on devrait faire
et non pas sur ce qui a été fait
et sur l'évaluation concrète aussi
objectiver que possible de ce qui a été
fait y compris ce serait intéressant
vous posez la question d'Astrid qu'à un
moment donné voilà les parlementaires
puissent prendre connaissance de
pourquoi ça n'a pas marché
pourquoi après avoir mis de l'argent de
l'argent de l'argent ça ne marchait pas
voilà
ça c'est une chose et l'autre chose
voilà c'est est-ce que alors je le dis
d'autant plus moi je vous parle
franchement que quand j'étais président
de l'Assemblée nationale sans doute
parce que je ne suis pas resté assez
longtemps et parce qu'il y avait pas une
volonté partagée par tout le monde j'ai
un peu échoué sur ce sujet le
gouvernement avait dit qu'il mettrait à
disposition du Parlement les experts de
France stratégie mais qui seraient
transférées sous l'autorité du Parlement
pour faire ce travail d'évaluation il
avait à peine fait cette proposition que
elle a été retirée j'ai dit on va
développer notre propre expertise notre
nos propres outils on pourrait
d'ailleurs y compris payer des experts
temporairement avoir des missions de six
mois d'un an de deux ans sur des sujets
sur lesquels il va y avoir des débats
législatifs bon ça n'a pas été suivi
après moi mais au-delà de cela c'est
aussi au député de se saisir des sujets
vous le faites et c'est très bien sur le
débat de la ltecv comme on l'a appelé la
loi de transition énergétique pour la
croissance verte en 2015 il y avait des
députés il y en a d'ailleurs autour de
cette table qui s'étaient saisi des
sujets qui avaient travaillé en amont je
crois pouvoir dire que j'en faisais
partie je crois pouvoir dire que
François brode qui était le rapporteur
de ce texte de loi allez travailler
depuis des années et des années sur ces
sujets après est-ce qu'il y avait assez
de personnes à l'Assemblée nationale
ayant travaillé sur ce sujet c'est une
autre question et je me souviens d'un
ancien président de Dave qui m'avait dit
il y a trop peu de responsables
politiques à s'intéresser aux enjeux
énergétiques et alors même que nous
n'avions pas le même point de vue il m'a
dit je reconnais au moins vous êtes
quelques-uns vous êtes vraiment
intéressé à ces sujets en tant que
député oui mais pas que d'ailleurs
l'électricité vous disiez le gaz le
pétrole etc bon voilà et bon ça après un
moment donné il faut député de s'en
saisir après c'est sûr que si on préfère
faire des tweets qui font des millions
de vues parce que on aura fait de la
provocation ou aller dans des émissions
de télé où on préfère s'empailler avec
des symboles etc bon bah c'est sûr qu'on
prendra pas les bonnes décisions
je vous remercie juste une insiste parce
que vous l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure et
comme vous l'avez évoqué dans les mêmes
termes ici je voulais voir une précision
sur Astrid vous dites là vous avez dit
c'est intéressant comme ça passionne
tout le monde aujourd'hui alors qu'à
l'époque ça n'intéressait strictement
personne je tiens quand même à le dire
nous ça nous a toujours intéressé je
pense
parce que je suis pas sûr d'avoir
compris vous avez dit ça n'a pas marché
parce que dans ce que j'ai compris il y
avait un avant projet qui arrivait à son
terme et dont les travaux sont allés à
leur terme aux alentours de 2017-2018 et
c'est ensuite posé la question de
transformer ses travaux enfin de
transformer l'essai si j'ose dire et de
faire que ces travaux puissent être mis
en oeuvre d'un point de vue
non pas industriel d'ailleurs exactement
mais d'un point de vue expérimental et
si j'ai bien suivi des discussions qu'on
a eu avec Daniel verver notamment mais
mais pas que la question qui s'est
ensuite posée c'est celle de faire de la
simulation numérique et donc l'idée
c'était de pouvoir répliquer le réacteur
Astrid qui finalement n'a pas été
construit en une simulation numérique
mais vous ce que vous dites face autant
ce que je comprends dans ce que vous
dites c'est que les travaux de recherche
n'auraient pas été n'auraient pas abouti
vous n'aurez pas été fructueux c'est ça
sur le nucléaire en France depuis
plusieurs dizaines d'années
on dépense énormément d'argent dans des
programmes de recherche à des niveaux
divers c'est à dire qui ont vocation à
aboutir plus ou moins loin dans le temps
je rappelle
que dans le même temps la plus personne
n'en parle tout le monde se focalise sur
Astrid mais plus personne ne parle d'un
énorme projet international qui coûte
chaque année des sommes très importantes
qui est ITER
donc à un moment donné un gouvernement
fait le choix de dire on ne peut pas
courir tous les sujets parce qu'il faut
remettre de l'argent parce que la
technologie n'est toujours pas au point
après les simulations de refaire et on
demande à l'état de remettre de l'argent
vous savez que c'est toujours ça sera la
dernière fois mais sauf que ceux alors
là il faudrait évidemment peut-être
parfois avoir plus dans la durée mais
ceux qui sont restés longtemps en poste
devraient reconnaître que de conseils de
politique nucléaire en Conseil de
politique nucléaire on redemandait de
toujours remettre de l'argent je peux
vous dire qu'on m'a dit je ne sais
combien de fois y compris les diplomates
du ministère des Affaires étrangères
vous voyez qu'on prend la vie des
diplomates du ministère des Affaires
étrangères sont des sujets comme ça je
crois pas qu'ils aient une compétence
technique sur le sujet qui nous dit si
si vous savez il va y avoir des
commandes bientôt de réacteurs français
en Inde
vous les avez vu les commandes d'un
acteur français en Inde ça fait des
années qu'on en parle c'est vrai il y en
a pas oui mais peut-être au Brésil on va
y arriver rien en Chine il y aura
d'autres développements que
tihan il y en a pas eu en
Grande-Bretagne oui non mais ils sont
prêts à nous recommander un réacteur
plus petit que le père
moi justement je fais le travail je suis
pas comme a dit Monsieur bréchet on
n'est pas des oiseaux
donc moi je suis allé voir les ministres
anglais et où est-ce que vous en êtes
qu'est-ce que vous êtes prêts à faire
non pour l'instant on n'y touche pas on
a recommandé en clapoint on va au bout
mais là on est on va à fond sur le le
l'éolien en mer donc à un moment donné
on va toujours sur ITER on soutient iteh
on fait des choix ça coûte de l'argent
et bien oui on décide de ne pas se
disperser sous azimut peut-être que
c'est sur le nougat peut-être que c'est
un tort mais il faudrait quand même
qu'on fasse le compte un jour de tout ce
qu'on a dépensé dans des programmes de
recherche dont certains n'ont jamais
abouti alors que ce n'est pas dans le
coût de l'électricité
vous savez que sur le pétrole par
exemple
si total fait des projets de recherche
c'est dans les comptes de Total
l'Institut français du pétrole et des
énergies nouvelles il est cofinancé par
les industriels du secteur bon voilà
c'est l'automobile
et secteur industriel majeur pour la
France des enjeux majeurs les batteries
etc l'hydrogène c'est des yards parfois
des subventions de l'État mais c'est
dans le but que ça que ça aboutisse
voilà c'est ça le le sujet sur Astrid
apprécie un jour il y a dans plusieurs
pays dans le monde aussi ici là c'est en
train d'aboutir on relance le sujet
pourquoi pas de toute façon le savoir le
savoir accumuler par nos chercheurs par
nos laboratoires n'est pas perdus moi
j'entends parler de nouvelles
technologies sur le nucléaire vraiment
de petits nucléaires enfin ou de remise
au goût du jour de technologie anciennes
très bien mais c'est avec des gens qui
nous disent ça nous permettra de
produire de l'électricité un coût
inférieur à celui qui est les coûts
d'aujourd'hui voilà c'est quand même la
question du coup quand même pas la
balayer d'un revers de la main
puisque vous parlez du coup j'ai deux
dernières questions je les pose
peut-être séparément pour pour la
lisibilité de nos débats puisque vous
parlez du coup et puisque vous l'avez
vous même abordé tout à l'heure je
voulais avoir votre votre avis et votre
récit sur la relation entre l'État et
EDF
puisque vous arrivez au responsabilités
quelques mois avant le rapport fold
enfin le rapport difols qui fait un état
des lieux du chantier EPR mais qui
au-delà du strict chantier EPR est une
sorte de carottage dans l'entreprise EDF
et qui j'imagine dit un certain nombre
de choses
quels sont quel est l'état de vos
relations avec EDF d'abord dans quel
état vous trouvez l'entreprise à votre
arrivée les anciens responsables de DF
les organisations représentatives du
personnel nous ont parlé de la reine on
en a on a déjà évoqué le sujet et on
semblait dire en réponse en tout cas à
nos questions que c'était la principale
cause des difficultés financières
ajouter avec un ajout celle du signal
envoyé par la loi de 2004 enfin l'accord
de 2012 et la loi 2015 sur la sortie
progressive du nuque enfin la réduction
de la part du nucléaire expliquant qu'à
ces deux causes j'allais dire signal
politique et cause financière on
trouvait la conséquence
l'affaiblissement de l'entreprise la
dégradation du niveau de sous-traitance
la gestion de projet etc quel est votre
avis sur ces constats et votre
expérience de ministre
pour cette question extrêmement
importante
d'abord
quand moi j'étais ministre
je pense que mon agenda en fait en
ferait foi c'est avec le président d'EDF
que j'ai passé le plus de temps de
toutes les entreprises relevant du
secteur de mon ministère qui pourtant
était bien plus vaste et elle est bien
au-delà évidemment non seulement de
l'énergie mais en particulier de
l'électricité et d'EDF ça me paraissait
normal c'est une grande entreprise qui
assure l'essentiel de la production
d'électricité en France par ailleurs
c'est une grande entreprise en
difficulté depuis de très nombreuses
années j'ai vu d'ailleurs que dans vos
auditions un ancien PDG d'EDF monsieur
Gadonneix a dit que quand il était
arrivé en 2004 en 2004
il y avait pas de loi de transition
énergétique et pas de choses comme ça il
a été assez inquiet alors peut-être
qu'il réécrit l'histoire mais je prends
quand même ce qu'il dit pour quelque
chose de sérieux inquiet du voir de voir
que l'entreprise n'investissait
quasiment plus
ni pour développer des capacités de
production ni pour l'entretenir la
maintenance la rénovation
et par ailleurs
il dit que il y avait déjà un problème
d'équilibre entre les coûts
et les recettes alors il met ça sur le
compte du fait que les prix de
l'électricité aura été baissé par le
pouvoir politique dans les années
précédentes je vous laisse le soin
évidemment de vérifier tout cela et il
rappelle
que quand il était président et je m'en
souviens très bien puisque là j'étais
député entre temps depuis 2007 il dit
dans une interview à la presse qui le
souhaiterait que les prix de
l'électricité augmentent de 20% en 4 ans
et que à l'époque cette demande lui a
coûté le renouvellement de son poste qui
n'a pas été reconduit en 2009 à l'issue
de son mandat à cause de ça et je peux
témoigner que ça a fait énormément de
polémiques politiques à l'époque vous
rendez compte aujourd'hui 20% en 4 ans
comme ça paraît peu par rapport au prix
que hausse de prix que nous subissons
je pense que la relation entre le
pouvoir politique qui doit avoir le
dernier mot alors ça ne plaît peut-être
pas certains syndicats qui sont habitués
à tout gérer dans une grande maison qui
est quand même par ailleurs une grande
maison très opaque dans laquelle il y a
des statues très particuliers déjà il y
a le statut des industries électriques
et gazières qui s'applique à tout les
industriels du secteur mais en plus il y
a le statut de DF au passage je vous le
dis quand même puisqu'il y a beaucoup de
débats sur les retraites j'ai entendu
l'autre jour un syndicaliste EDF dire
que le régime spécial de retraite d'EDF
c'est l'équilibré bah oui c'est
l'équilibre parce qu'il y a une petite
ligne sur la facture des consommateurs
d'électricité pour payer le régime
spécial quand même un peu gros si on
faisait ça dans tous les secteurs ça
serait quand même un peu particulier et
bien en effet je pense que les relations
sont souvent difficiles entre le pouvoir
politique et
l'entreprise EDF car l'entreprise EDF a
été habituée pendant de très nombreuses
années pendant plusieurs décennies à ce
qu'il n'y ait pas de débat politique sur
la politique énergétique de la France et
à ce qu'il n'y ait pas de loi en la
matière et à ce qu'on défende ses
intérêts mais qui ont alors je peux dire
qu'en tant que ministre
oui nous avons passé beaucoup de temps
et pris beaucoup de décisions pour faire
en sorte que des f ne fasse pas faillite
et je dois dire que le président Macron
ça a été une préoccupation constante de
sa part c'est aussi un sujet dont il m'a
parlé avant même de me nommer
alors qu'il avait été ministre de
l'Économie je le rappelle entre 2015 et
entre 2014 pardon et 2016 pendant deux
ans et qu'il savait donc ce qu'il en
était
qu'il avait déjà soulevé la question je
me souviens très bien d'ailleurs ici
même à l'Assemblée nationale dans une
réponse à aux questions au gouvernement
il dit après avoir la signature du
contrat inclipoint et il dit maintenant
il faudra que EDF fasse des efforts de
compétitivité de productivité et il cite
noir sur blanc le cou du statut de DF
pour
la compétitivité de DF
quand j'étais ministre donc nous avons à
la fois veillé à cela et
évidemment considérer que la définition
de la politique énergétique de la France
de la politique des choix sur la
politique électrique de la France
relevait du pouvoir politique du
gouvernement avec le Parlement
d'ailleurs nous avons y compris quand
moi j'étais ministre
proposé une loi qui parlait d'un certain
nombre de sujets et c'est tout à fait
normal que ça se passe ainsi comme dans
les autres secteurs mais ça n'était pas
l'habitude c'est une quelque chose
héritage du passé très très ancien je
veux quand même rappeler que le
Président de la République
avec proposé une réorganisation d'EDF
sur laquelle nous avons travaillé quand
j'étais ministre qui s'appelait le
projet Hercule
donc sans doute EDF ne voulait pas
beaucoup d'ailleurs les syndicats ne le
voulaient pas du tout ça c'est sûr le
pouvoir politique agit comme dans
d'autres secteurs mais particulièrement
dans celui-là sous la menace de conflits
sociaux durs avec la menace de coupure
d'électricité avec la menace de grève
qui porteraient atteinte à
l'alimentation en électricité de la
France c'est quelque chose qui est assez
lourd et c'est assez unique je dois le
dire je rappelle que dans le ministère
de l'écologie j'avais également la
tutelle dans les transports sur la SNCF
sur la RATP sur Air France sur beaucoup
de grandes entreprises où il y a aussi
des sujets où il y a aussi des
conflictualités mais jamais à ce niveau
donc voilà c'est c'est un état de fait
il faut le savoir il faut pas d'ailleurs
diaboliser mon prédécesseur avait
beaucoup dit que le problème c'était les
lobbies moi je l'ai dit c'est dans
l'interview dans le monde
septembre 2018 qui vaut mieux d'ailleurs
accepter de considérer que oui il y a
des intérêts particuliers qui
se font entendre et qui défendent leur
point de vue ça fait partie du débat
c'est tout à fait normal en revanche
faut pas laisser croire que c'est
d'intérêt général et moi je ne je pense
que vous êtes parlementaire vous êtes
détenteur en tout cas une fois que vous
avez débattu et que vous faites des
bottes de la définition de l'intérêt
général ce n'est pas le cas ni de la
direction ni des syndicats d'EDF
merci une dernière question pour ma part
sur la programmation pluriannuelle de
l'énergie nous avait présenté un projet
à l'époque
puisqu'on parlait de chiffres tout à
l'heure
quel est le fondement de la décision de
mettre ce chiffre de 14
réacteurs nucléaire à fermer à un
horizon assez proche et est-ce que
au travers de chiffres il y avait
implicitement l'idée que serait prise la
décision quelques années avant quelques
mois ou années après en fonction de
l'aboutissement de flamants ville et de
la capacité de la filière à répondre à
la question de relancer de nouveaux
réacteurs sous-entendus est-ce que
c'était une réduction de la part du
nucléaire une sortie du nucléaire ou la
préparation d'un renouvellement
c'était d'abord fondé là aussi dans des
plaises à certains qui veulent faire
croire que les politiques sont les
incompétents qui prennent des décisions
en l'air sans avoir consulté personne ce
qui ne correspond pas la réalité c'est
assez énervant quand même je puis ne
laissez pas dire cela vous êtes des
politiques vous êtes des députés ne
laissez pas dire que vous prenez des
décisions sur dans des émissions de
téléréalité non ou sur des tweets vous
prenez des décisions parce que vous avez
travaillé sur des sujets et bien les
ministres en tout cas moi j'ai passé
énormément de temps évidemment ça se
voit pas je faisais pas un twitch chaque
fois que je faisais une réunion ou que
j'avais un échange avec Monsieur Lévi
dans mon bureau président d'EDF ou avec
le Commissariat au CEA où est situé
c'est normal j'allais pas me mettre en
scène chaque fois que je faisais une
réunion de travail quand même et bien
nous avons discuté je peux vous dire
qu'on y a passé beaucoup de temps ce qui
est normal d'un certain nombre de
scénarios sur la consommation ce qui
commande c'est quel sera le niveau de
consommation d'électricité c'est
difficile à définir consommation
française consommation européenne et
qu'elle peut être de production qu'on
met en face pour que on ne soit pas en
situation de surproduction ou de
sous-production sachant qu'on n'a pas
beaucoup de capacité de stockage même si
les barrages hydroélectriques peuvent
servir parfois de tampon et nous avions
des schémas
travailler avec des polytechniciens
alors je sais pas si pour Monsieur
bréchet les polytechniciens sont des
oiseaux mais moi je ne considère pas je
ne suis pas je précise je ne défends pas
ma chapelle avec des gens du ministère
de l'économie et des finances avec des
gens des différents bien sûr avec les
gens d'EDF pour ce qui concernait le
parc nucléaire sur voilà comment on
pourrait évoluer comment on pourrait
faire de la programmation de la
planification sur les moyens de
production nucléaire les autres on ne
parle pas beaucoup des autres moi je me
suis battu dans la programmation plus
rien de énergie pour augmenter les
perspectives de production d'éoliens en
mer aujourd'hui tout le monde semble
d'accord mais à l'époque je peux vous
dire que c'était sacré bras de fer
que des régions d'ailleurs ont poussé
aussi dans ce sens là je me suis battu
sur le biogaz quand je vois aujourd'hui
les difficultés qu'on a sur
l'approvisionnement en gaz je me dis que
c'est ça aurait été bien qu'on
intensifie plus vite plutôt sur ces
questions sur la sobriété évidemment sur
la chaleur renouvelable toutes ces
sujets là mi bout à bout on essaye de
faire des scénarios et évidemment avec
la perspective que vous avez vous-même
parfaitement comprise qui était qu'il y
aurait une substitution progressive de
vieux réacteurs nucléaires de plus de 40
ans conçu je le rappelle au départ et je
j'ai vu que monsieur gallanex par
exemple confirmait dans son audition
pour être pour 40 ans qui s'il devait
être prolongé deux et faire l'objet de
nouveaux investissements mais qui
pouvait à terme être remplacé
progressivement par des nouveaux
réacteurs de type EPR
et avec des perspectives de consommation
qui avait vocation à augmenter mais je
vous rappelle qu'à l'époque en 2018 2019
nous n'étions pas du tout dans les mêmes
perspectives qu'aujourd'hui sur
l'électrification des transports
notamment de la voiture à l'époque dans
les gilets jaunes moi je suis allé sur
des ronds-points j'ai discuté avec les
gilets jaunes dans les médias dans les
toutes les réseaux qu'ils avaient ils
avaient entre autres vraiment tête de
turc la voiture électrique nous avions
des débats ici à l'Assemblée nationale
au niveau européen aussi jamais non ça
marchera pas il faut pas en faire les
mêmes débats il faut pas faire de la
batterie ça sert plus à rien faut
peut-être aller sur l'hydrogène mais bon
on verra un autre jour etc les moteurs
thermiques vont continuer à s'améliorer
pourquoi financer des programmes de
recherche sur l'hydrogène
vers mon prédécesseur était un militant
de l'hydrogène je dois le dire il
n'avait pas du tout été suivi au sein du
Gouvernement sur ce point et bien entre
temps en effet il y a eu d'autres
décisions qui ont été prises au niveau
français comme au niveau européen de
développer l'utilisation de
l'électricité pour décarboner l'économie
et que ça ça nécessite en effet des
moyens de production supplémentaire qui
n'étaient pas forcément envisagée à 5
ans
madame baptistel
merci monsieur le Président je sais pas
si vous souhaitez que je déroule mes 5
questions ou si je les sépare
merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre merci pour pour ces
premiers échanges alors j'aurais
plusieurs questions je commencerai et
c'est pas mon habitude
sur ce que vous avez dit concernant le
moratoire de 2010 sur le photovoltaïque
que vous aviez l'air de regretter et
vous disiez cela était cette décision a
été prise puisque ça marchait trop bien
alors est-ce que c'est parce que à cette
époque
n'a pas été
réfléchi le dispositif que nous avons
pris plus tard c'est à dire le
complément de rémunération pour
permettre justement de calibrer le
soutien
aux porteur de projet d'énergie
renouvelable et ou alors est-ce que vous
considérez que c'est parce que
c'était une énergie une production
d'énergie qui allait contre le nucléaire
et qui du coup n'était pas très
très intéressante
que j'ai voulu dire c'est que en 2010 le
gouvernement de l'époque et c'était
Nathalie Kosciusko-Morizet qui était
nouvellement ministre de l'écologie
décide de faire un moratoire sur tout
développement de projet solaire
photovoltaïques compris le plus petit
c'est une personne qui voulait mettre
quelques mètres carrés de panneaux sur
son toit c'était stoppé net mais ça a
été du jour au lendemain et ça a duré
pendant six mois avant qu'un nouveau
dispositif soit mis en oeuvre ça
constitue comme conséquence de casser
une filière avec
13000 personnes mais comme c'était des
installateurs des petites entreprises de
quelques salariés ça n'a pas ému grand
monde alors que vous imaginez si dans le
même temps on avait annoncé 13000
suppressions d'emplois EDF ou chez
Renault ou chez Alstom moi j'ai le
souvenir de quand le PDG de Peugeot a
annoncé quelques milliers de suppression
d'emploi il a été convoqué à l'Elysée
bon donc à ce ce moment là c'est un
choix qui pour moi est aberrant au lieu
de faire en effet décroître
progressivement les subventions le tarif
d'achat garantie ce qui était tout à
fait logique puisque les prix des
panneaux avaient fortement baissé donc
il y avait plus besoin d'autant de
subventions mais plus besoin d'un tarif
d'achat garanti aussi généreux et bien
il suffisait de le faire baisser dans le
temps ce qui est ensuite été fait et à
ce moment là on aurait
gardé une bonne dynamique sur le solaire
photovoltaïque qu'on a retrouvé depuis
il faut être positif ça n'a pas été
heureusement quelque chose de définitif
mais quand même on a perdu du temps je
mets ça a été le cas dans plusieurs
domaines et c'est regrettable l'éolien
offshore en mer je rappelle quand même
que les premières décisions de lancer y
compris la délimitation de parcs dans
plusieurs régions de France date de la
présidence de Nicolas Sarkozy
et le premier parc a été inauguré dans
le deuxième mandat d'Emmanuel Macron
c'est comme si il a fallu quatre
présidents donc à trois
c'est quand même quelque chose qui n'est
pas normal en France il faut que on
aille plus vite sur le développement des
capacités de production on a besoin
d'ailleurs de toutes les capacités de
production et donc surtout de ne pas
casser quand il y a des dynamiques qui
existent dans des secteurs comme c'était
le cas à l'époque dans le solaire
photovoltaïque donc moi je considère
mais bon voilà c'est le passé que
c'était une erreur à ce moment-là oui
donc on peut considérer que ce mot
atteindre nous a fait perdre quelques
années de développement du
photovoltaïque qu'on regrette sûrement
maintenant encore
sur votre propos concernant la stabilité
que vous avez trouvé en arrivant sur le
nucléaire qui était très stable et vous
disiez l'hydro également on avait quand
même à cette époque la question de la
mise en concurrence qui était sur nos
têtes je parlais de la production oui
mais qui du coup mettait un frein à une
dynamique d'investissement
d'investissement et ou un potentiel
d'investissement
les différents gouvernements successifs
féministes successifs n'ont pas réussi à
convaincre
constat la Commission européenne du bien
fondé de notre demande de non mise en
concurrence de cette de cet outil
pour votre part est-ce que vous avez
contribué à tenter quelque chose où vous
avez pas eu
suffisamment de temps pour le faire et
la deuxième ce que vous disiez sur
l'hydroélectricité c'est qu'il y a pas
de potentiel nouveau parce qu'on se voit
pas noyer une je voudrais quand même
insister sur le fait que on a beaucoup
de possibilités de d'augmentation de
puissance sur les barrages existants et
qui sont aussi liés pour beaucoup à
cette situation un peu de mise en
demeure de la Commission européenne qui
du coup ne permet pas aux exploitants de
de d'investir sur sur ces outils et donc
de ne pas développer voilà donc sur le
deuxième c'est un constat sur la
première est-ce que vous avez eu à
négocier avec la Commission européenne
pour cela nous avons eu à l'époque de
nombreux échanges à ce sujet
j'allais le dire et j'espère que les à
la fois les citoyennes et les citoyens
français qui partagent vos options
politiques ou qui sont dans votre
territoire sont bien conscients du
travail que vous faites sur ce sujet car
il est acharné et de longues haleine
donc même si je ne partage pas ni
totalement votre analyse ni vos
conclusions je dois vraiment saluer
cette continuité dans l'engagement et
l'expertise d'ailleurs que vous avez
développé puisque c'était un sujet dont
on parlait tout à l'heure sur ce sujet
d'abord peut-être une remarque générale
j'ai essayé de le dire tout à l'heure
c'est vrai que c'est un secteur qui est
un peu oublié en France
parce que là aussi ça fait partie du
paysage ça marche ça produit de
l'électricité ça sert à l'équilibrage de
notre réseau y compris d'ailleurs il
faut pas le l'oublier au fonctionnement
des centrales nucléaires parce que il y
a un élément sur le refroidissement en
été etc sur les niveaux d'eau donc c'est
quelque chose qui finalement
n'est pas tellement un sujet de
quand on parle de l'avenir des
investissements à faire des choix c'est
un peu dommage parce que c'est en effet
un secteur qui reprenait qui qui est
intéressant et qui a un potentiel alors
qui n'est quand même pas non plus énorme
dans la mesure où il s'agit en effet
d'améliorer la production mais sur les
installations existantes
en général on considère que dans les
hypothèses les plus optimistes peut-être
10 à 15%
alors ne rentrons pas dans une querelle
je vous fais crédit mais j'ai vu
d'autres exemples sur le rôle qui sont
très inférieurs à 10% mais bon quand
j'étais ministre
moi j'avais proposé au gouvernement que
nous ayons une négociation globale avec
la Commission européenne
sur la reine
moi je souhaitais qu'on relève le prix
très clairement de mieux rémunérer EDF
sur la reine
et sur à l'époque il y avait le projet
Hercule et sur la question des barrages
je n'ai pas été suivi contact c'est
comme ça dans la vie d'un gouvernement
on n'est pas toujours suivi c'est pas
grave on peut continuer à agir en
segmentant les choses
je constate que ça n'a pas abouti ni sur
Hercule bon sur la reine à la marge et
sur les barrages c'est le statu quo je
dois dire aussi que le Président de la
République
et ces différents gouvernements ce sont
toujours engagés
pour défendre le fait que pour l'instant
il n'y avait pas de mise en concurrence
remise en concurrence à la fin des
concessions
des concessions des barrages
hydroélectriques français
je rappelle quand même ça c'est un point
de désaccord que nous avons avec Madame
batistel que ça n'est pas d'abord et
avant tout une obligation européenne
c'est d'abord et avant tout le droit des
concessions le principe d'une concession
c'est qu'elle est accordée pour une
certaine durée tous les élus locaux le
savent par exemple quand ils font une
concession pour un parking ils le font
pour 25 pour 30 ans quand il faut une
concession pour une station d'épuration
ils le font pareil pour 15 20 25 ans et
puis à un moment donné la collectivité
remet en jeu la concession soit elle en
reprend la gestion propre soit elle
confie soit au même opérateur soit un
autre les aéroports il y a des
concessions réservoir et ainsi de suite
la France d'ailleurs a inventé le droit
de la concession il faut en être fier
parce que c'est ce qui permet de
financer par des investissements privés
des équipements d'intérêt général qui je
le rappelle reste dans le domaine public
car dans le même temps ou donc les
gouvernements successifs y compris celui
auquel j'ai appartenu ont résisté à
l'application de la loi française et
européenne sur le droit des concessions
EDF a une époque est allé acheter un
barrage dans d'autres pays et là c'était
acheter l'infrastructure c'était pas la
concession c'était l'infrastructure je
suis désolé c'est un peu technique
peut-être pour celles et ceux qui nous
suivent enfin je crois que c'est quand
même assez facile à comprendre que dans
un cas on vous confie l'exploitation
d'un équipement pendant X années en
général une longue durée pour amortir
des investissements et produire de
l'électricité dans un autre cas on vous
vend l'équipement en France il n'a
jamais été question de privatiser les
barrages je le dis et le redis
contrairement à ce que disent un certain
nombre de syndicalistes ou de
responsable politique de gauche il a
toujours été question simplement de
savoir si on remettait en concurrence la
concession démarrage ou pas après il y
avait une question on rentre encore un
peu plus dans la précision enfin comme
on nous dit que les ministres sont pas
précis qui connaissent pas les dossiers
techniques bon et bien désolé je vais
être un peu technique
c'est que à un moment donné il y a un
choix à faire et ça madame batistel vous
le savez très bien on en a déjà discuté
quand j'étais ministre soit on dit qu'on
ne veut plus jamais en tout cas sur un
certain nombre de barrages faire de
remise en concurrence à l'échéance des
concessions et on met les barrages dans
une société publique comme on dit une
régie d'État séparé séparé def et donc
EDF ne pourrait plus jouer de la
synergie de la complémentarité entre
l'exploitation des barrages et le reste
de ces outils de production notamment
les centrales nucléaires moi je pense
que ce ne serait pas dans l'intérêt
d'EDF ce ne serait pas dans l'intérêt du
système électrique français et donc si
on considère qu'on ne veut pas séparer
totalement les barrages du reste
il vaudrait mieux à mon sens
au fil de l'eau c'est le cas de le dire
que les concessions soient renouvelées
et EDF pourraient
concourir puisque j'avais négocié avec
la Commission européenne et le
gouvernement a toujours été sur cette
position là mais les gouvernements
précédents également sur le fait que
EDF puisse concourir alors qu'elle est
en situation dominante c'est un fait
objectif sur les barrages je rappelle
qu'il est en France d'autres acteurs
la Compagnie nationale du Rhône et la
chaîne donc on ne parle pas que des
éventuelles investisseurs étrangers ou
d'autres groupes privés en l'occurrence
voilà c'est un débat pour l'instant
c'est le statut quo là où nous sommes
d'accord c'est que le statu quo a un
immense inconvénient c'est qu'il empêche
de lancer les investissements et donc ça
c'est tout à fait dommageable et donc je
pense que le Parlement d'ailleurs
devrait se saisir de ce sujet dans les
prochaines lois sur l'énergie pour que
il y ait une option qui soit prise soit
c'est tout est mis dans une société
publique séparée d'EDF soit au fil de
l'eau il y a un renouvellement normal
selon le droit de la concession
merci monsieur le ministre de toute
façon nous ne tomberons pas d'accord
mais nous ne sommes pas là pour ça
c'était simplement pour avoir un
éclairage sur sur le passé et du coup
deux questions
qui me sont qui me viennent après votre
intervention est-ce que vous considérez
que
si on passait du régime concessif au
régime d'autorisation puisque c'est des
discussions qui quelquefois viennent sur
la table ce serait mieux et la deuxième
chose vous disiez que vous étiez
favorable finalement à une remise en
concurrence et que les candidats
français évidemment pourraient ce qui
est fort heureusement pourrait concourir
est-ce que ça contribue pas tout de même
s'il ne gagnait pas ses marchés à une
perte de souveraineté de énergétique de
la France l'objet de notre commission
d'abord il y a un choix politique qui
est qui peut à tout moment être débattu
qui est tout à fait légitime il y a des
gens qui pensent d'une manière générale
que ce qui est public est toujours mieux
qu'une entreprise publique c'est mieux
qu'une entreprise privée qu'une
entreprise ou qu'un voir une
administration de l'État voire un
établissement public c'est mieux que une
gestion privée ce n'est pas mon point de
vue ça je et je pense que ce n'est pas
le point de vue du président et du
gouvernement actuel mais c'est je ne
m'exprimerai pas alors place moi je
pense que le système des concessions est
un bon système puisqu'il permet de
financer des investissements importants
qui sont nécessaires nous sommes bien
d'accord sur ce point qui sont
nécessaires dans le domaine des barrages
hydroélectriques qui sont nécessaires
dans d'autres domaines
ça ne choque personne que les éoliennes
en mer se soient des concessions de fait
c'est pour 25 ans 20 ans
des gens exploite des investissements
qu'ils ont eux-mêmes financé et ils
arrivent le réseau électrique qui lui
est national et mutualisé et même
connecté au niveau européen donc voilà
je pense que de ce point de vue là ce
serait bien de continuer dans ce que la
France fait depuis je crois au moins 150
ans pour encore une fois avoir des
équipements publics mais qui sont gérés
par des entreprises qui vont chercher de
l'argent privé pour faire fonctionner
ces équipements au service d'un réseau
électrique national au passage je le dis
d'ailleurs ça c'est un petit sujet dont
on parle pas beaucoup
ne commençons pas d'une façon d'une
autre à démembrer le réseau
je pense qu'il serait bien de prendre
des garanties législatives nouvelles
c'est mon expérience ministérielle qui
m'a instruit cela sur le réseau de
tension il y a pas trop de risques c'est
clair avec RTE sur le réseau local il y
a des collectivités locales qui
commencent régime de la concession à
vouloir le reprendre en propre
à vouloir créer des sociétés locales
attention le réseau électrique c'est la
garantie que on a la meilleure sécurité
d'approvisionnement et une solidarité
entre les habitants des différents
territoires de France et de Navarre
monsieur le ministre puisque vous parlez
démantèlement ça me fait rebondir sur la
question du projet Hercule qu'est-ce que
vous trouviez comme vertu à ce projet
Hercule qui pour un certain nombre de
personnes à la fois des syndicats mais
pas que
fragiliser le système intégré de
l'entreprise et
on séparant un certain nombre
d'activités notamment enedis dont vous
venez de parler et aujourd'hui tout le
monde convient que ça pouvait quand même
être une erreur et qu'il serait bien que
enedis reviennent dans le paquet bleu
qui était prédéfini préalablement
j'ai Hercule il est mort donc bon
Hercule n'a pas eu assez de force mais
ceci est dit c'est très intéressant d'en
reparler deux minutes parce que c'est un
lien à mon avis très étroit avec le
sujet de votre commission
je pense que c'est utile de dire deux
trois choses qui n'ont pas été beaucoup
expliciteaux français parce que c'était
de fête un sujet entre le gouvernement
EDF et les syndicats à l'intérieur de
def
ça a été envisagé le projet Hercule
pour une raison dans le fond assez
simple et assez facile à comprendre
c'était une façon un de remettre le parc
nucléaire dans une société 100% public
depuis ça a été fait sous une autre
forme mais c'était déjà l'ambition du
projet Hercule et je peux le dire sans
risque d'être démenti l'ambition
d'Emmanuel Macron il m'en avait parlé là
aussi avant que de me nommer ministre et
que j'accepte d'être nommé ministre
2 il s'agissait de financer le nouveau
nucléaire
il faut pas tourner autour du pot
c'était une façon
de
encore une fois mettre
la partie nucléaire à la brille entre
guillemets des risques de la cotation
boursière je pense que je ne sais pas si
vous avez auditionné monsieur Clamadieu
président d'engie ou je crois que vous
avez auditionné la directrice générale
je ne sais pas si vous l'ont dit mais de
fait engie souffre beaucoup à souffert
et souffre beaucoup d'avoir un petit
parc nucléaire mais d'avoir un parc
nucléaire en Belgique et chaque fois
qu'il y a quelque chose qui est délicat
soit du point de vue de la sûreté soit
du point de vue de décision ça les
fragilise
inutilement
et au-delà de ça donc financer par un
montage qui était un peu compliqué
il venait pas de moi je le dis il ne
venait pas non plus du ministre de
l'économie je crois qu'on peut le dire
de il s'est exprimé à plusieurs reprises
avant même que le projet soit abandonné
pour faire comprendre qu'il n'y était
pas très favorable et en l'occurrence
c'était pour grâce en effet à la vente
d'un certain nombre de parts pas du
réseau mais d'un certain nombre
d'actions
de d'un entité dans laquelle il y aurait
eu enedis et les énergies renouvelables
ce qui était un peu baroque à mon sens
d'ailleurs de financer le nouveau
nucléaire bon voilà moi je pense mais ça
c'est vraiment mon point de vue je n'ai
pas du tout travaillé là-dessus quand
j'étais ministre parce que il y avait ce
projet Hercule qui voilà était à
l'époque l'orientation que il serait
plus sain
d'aller au bout de la séparation de la
production et du transport et de la
distribution ce ne sont pas les mêmes
métiers ce ne sont pas les mêmes
exigences RTE et enedis font vivre un
réseau qui doit absolument être national
et qui est à disposition de tous les
producteurs depuis le plus petit
producteur qui met des panneaux solaires
sur son toit jusqu'au plus gros qui
installent des éoliennes en mer et ça
c'est une chose et moi je plaiderais
pour que ce soit des entités publiques
non coté en bourse
et d'avoir une entité pour la production
ou donc EDF en l'occurrence qui puisse
bénéficier à plein des éventuels
synergies entre les différents modes de
production et puis il y aura d'autres il
y en a déjà ngi total d'autres
entreprises de plus petites tailles
Enercoop etc qui continueront à produire
de l'électricité en France qui vont
investir davantage dans les années à
venir c'est à souhaiter dans des
nouveaux moyens de production qui au
passage quand même là aussi dans le
contexte chose qu'on a complètement
oublié à une époque totale mais envisagé
d'investir sur le nucléaire
par ailleurs le pouvoir politique je
pense notamment le président Sarkozy ou
l’interrogerait le souhaitait ou
souhaitait aussi que le groupe Bouygues
s'investisse sur le nucléaire d'ailleurs
le groupe Bouygues avait été appelé à la
rescousse par rapport à ces groupes
privés ont finalement fait le choix
stratégique de ne pas le faire parce que
c'est compliqué c'est risqué ces risques
y compris économiquement et donc de fait
c'est l'entreprise EDF qui est en France
le fait et le fera
ce Président si vous permet d'une petite
dernière j'ai un peu abusé ce soir mais
habituellement je suis plus concise
et comme je suis toute seule je me dis
que bon
sur la question de la reine pour finir
avec le meilleur
vous avez dit que vous étiez favorable
au relèvement du plafond que vous avez
du prix excusez-moi mais aussi du
plafond puisqu'il a été relevé en 2019
et c'est là où je veux en venir d'une
part vous disiez que
votre gouvernement veiller à ce que EDF
ne soit pas pénalisé financièrement
c'est une très bonne chose et en
parallèle le relèvement du plafond à une
époque où on savait qu'on avait une
indisponibilité d'une grande partie de
notre parc et que du coup la production
n'était plus de 380 terawatters mais de
moins de 300 sa pénalisé forcément EDF
que de relever le plafond donc est-ce
que cette discussion d'équilibre
économique de l'entreprise EDF a été
posée au moment où vous vous
réfléchissiez à ce relèvement du plafond
et puis vous disiez également que la
demande de que le relèvement du prix
vous y étiez favorable mais qu'il
fallait négocier avec la Commission
européenne ce que d'autres nous ont dit
ici dans cette commission qu'il n'y
avait pas d'obligation et que c'était
prévu dès le départ que le prix pouvait
évoluer donc je voulais aussi avoir
votre avis sur ce sujet
j'invite la commission son président
sont rapporteur à se procurer les
documents de l'époque de toute façon les
si jamais le gouvernement ne souhaitait
pas voler
et vous pourriez les obtenir en allant
ou même les chercher c'est la règle pour
les commissions d'enquête parlementaires
mais je pense que quand même pas besoin
d'aller jusque là c'est négociation
entre le gouvernement français et la
Commission européenne qui date de la fin
des années 99 c'est la loi sur
l'ouverture à la concurrence pour les
clients
entreprises et ensuite ça a été pour les
clients particuliers en 2007 je crois
de fait
alors c'est pareil on peut considérer
que la concurrence c'est pas bien que ça
n'apporte jamais rien de bon voilà c'est
pas l'orientation qui a été prise par la
Commission européenne Union européenne
l'Union européenne ça je l'ai vécu en
tant que ministre on va à des conseils
européens à 27 on négocie il y a jamais
de
de choses qui se font facilement parce
qu'il y a beaucoup de points de vue
différents et c'est normal des intérêts
différents et c'est normal donc on
construit des compromis à une époque
d'ailleurs je crois que c'était un
gouvernement socialiste c'était le
gouvernement de l'unan Jospin il y a eu
l'acceptation de d'avoir un marché
européen avec de la concurrence pour
permettre il faut quand même
se rappeler qu'à une époque en France
non seulement le consommateur ne pouvait
pas choisir son fournisseur
d'électricité il y avait quelques
exceptions dont l'Alsace et le
producteur
il y avait un monopole de la production
si vous aviez une technologie si vous
aviez développé une capacité à produire
l'électricité vous ne pouviez pas vendre
l'électricité que vous produisez vous
étiez obligé de la vendre à EDF est-ce
que c'était bien
est-ce que c'était bien est-ce que pour
développer par exemple les énergies
renouvelables parce qu'il faudrait
vraiment parler aussi de ça pourquoi
est-ce qu'en France on a mis tant de
temps et qu'on a pris le temps de retard
dans le développement des énergies
renouvelables non pas par rapport à des
objectifs chiffrés pour moi c'est pas ça
qui est important mais par rapport à
d'autres pays qui sont pas passés à côté
de cela qu'on a y compris des filières
industrielles en France
on a des
usines qui produisent des éoliennes par
exemple
et bien à un moment donné le
gouvernement français a accepté
dans le cadre d'un compromis européen
l'ouverture à la concurrence seulement
voilà si vous faisiez l'ouverture à la
concurrence en France
avec un acteur qu'avec tous les moyens
de production à quelques très rares
exceptions près quelques barrages
justement
et que vous attendiez que simplement par
des investissements d'entreprises dans
différents secteurs vous ayez de la
concurrence sur la production vous
risquez d'attendre longtemps c'était pas
de la vraie concurrence vous aviez le
choix entre EDF et EDF ou alors des
étrangers qui auraient fait venir de
l'électricité d'autres pays
parce que vous le savez très bien il y a
pas un opérateur autre qui se serait mis
à construire des centrales nucléaires et
pareil moi je pense pas que ce serait
souhaitable d'autres pays l'Allemagne
notamment avait plusieurs entreprises
gérant des centrales nucléaires vous
imaginez si on avait découpé EDF en
morceaux à l'époque personne ne l'aurait
souhaité alors surtout pas les syndicats
bon donc le choix a été fait de garder
l'unité de DF et il y a eu un compromis
de passer en disant bah voilà il y a une
part du volume de production qui doit
être mis à disposition des concurrents à
un prix qui doit couvrir les coûts de
production de DF sauf comme à l'époque
EDF disait qu'elle avait des coups de
production très bas c'est retrouver un
peu pris à son propre piège et donc avec
un prix à 42 qui est objectivement dans
le temps n'était pas suffisant et
je le rappelle sans téraweather sur une
production nucléaire vous allez
vous-même donner le chiffre de 350 en
moyenne
pendant 20 ans ou 30 ans mais en tout
cas depuis la période où la reine a été
signée donc depuis à peine 15 ans 12 ans
et bien c'est fait même pas un tiers et
ça a été relevé à 120 en janvier enfin
au début de l'année 2022 honnêtement je
pense que c'était quelque chose
d'équilibré de gagnant-gagnant par
rapport non seulement aux opérateurs
mais surtout par rapport au
consommateurs parce que je sais pas vous
mais moi je rencontre des entreprises
des y compris les petites entreprises
des hôteliers des restaurateurs des
boulangers etc à qui EDF propose des
contrats avec des prix de plus de 500
euros là actuellement
ça c'est pas la reine qui est
responsable de ça
les coûts de production de DF c'est pas
la reine qui est responsable de ça
il faut quand même que chacun prenne ses
responsabilités c'est ce que j'ai dit au
début de mon intervention d'abord qu'on
arrête de raconter n'importe quoi quand
j'entends y compris des responsables
politiques ou des syndicalistes qui ne
sont pas contredis par les journalistes
que les gens ils ne peuvent pas
connaître en effet la subtilité la
complexité de la reine des comptes on
oblige Joseph à vendre toute sa
production à des étrangers en plus des
étrangers oh là là des groupes privés oh
là là on est quand même bien contents
quand ils ont les entreprises privées
qui sont florissantes moi je préférerais
je veux dire ça aurait été plus facile à
gérer la programmation pluriannuelle de
l'énergie si EDF faisait des bénéfices
tous les ans
au lieu d'être obligé d'aller vendre les
investissements qui avaient été faits
par passer à l'étranger pour essayer
d'équilibrer les comptes ça s'appelle
vendre des bijoux de famille on est
toujours à tomber sur total à bras
raccourci enfin c'est quand même mieux
d'avoir des entreprises florissantes que
les entreprises qui sont en difficulté
financière c'est mieux pour tout le
monde pour l'économie générale du pays
comme pour les salariés de l'entreprise
concernée et je pense d'ailleurs que les
salariés d'EDF seraient peut-être un peu
moins en effet inquiet sur leur avenir
et donc en effet avec leurs syndicat un
peu crispé sur un certain nombre de
sujets s'ils avaient des perspectives
d'avenir florissantes et s'il pouvait se
dire maintenant c'est bon la reine ça va
arrêter en 2025 on se déploie on
démontre qu'on est capable de produire
de l'électricité de façon compétitive et
on convaincra les Français déjà bien sûr
d'acheter de l'électricité à EDF mais
aussi dans d'autres pays d'Europe par
qu'en France EDF a vocation à être un
leader énergétique en Europe et donc je
crois que cette histoire de la reine
finira assez vite par apparaître pour ce
que c'est à dire
l'arbre qui a un peu de mal à cacher la
forêt des autres problèmes
bien merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président pour votre disponibilité pour
vos réponses longues et précises je
crois que ça contribuera encore à
éclairer les travaux de notre commission
d'enquête nous poursuivrons donc avec
nos deux dernières auditions la semaine
prochaine celle de Nicolas Sarkozy jeudi
à 9h30 et celle de Monsieur François
Hollande je dis après-midi voilà merci
beaucoup pour votre disponible bonne
soirée à toutes et à tous merci